Jedes Mal, wenn die verkacken, ändern die ihren Namen.
Previously on Mobamex Xtreme.
Das erste ist in Mail, wenn man da Verlauf anschaltet.
Verlauf, jetzt mussten wir mal erst mal sagen, wie das auf Englisch heißt, weil ich benutze meinen Computer auf Gradient. Previously on die Mobile Max Wundertüte.
Los, lass mal den Roddy noch ein bisschen über Literals erzählen.
Na na.
Ich will, dass alles nicht hört.
Previously on früher war mehr Kalender.
Das heißt, wir kannst mal auf den Tischen.
Ja, jetzt pass auf, jetzt pass auf. Jetzt schnallt euch mal an. Jetzt sucht mal nochmal den Gold-Pest, ja?
Previously on Du kannst dir eine Wurst im Supermarkt ans Ohr halten und die Leute werden nicht darauf reagieren, wenn du anfängst mit ihr zu sprechen.
Herzlich willkommen bei Bum Zack Return.
Tja, ganz schön ganz schön ganz schön verspult. Du guckst mich schon wieder mit so einem gezwungenen Blick an.
Mein Kopfhörer explodiert. Also zum einen knistert es tatsächlich in der linken Ohrmuschel.
Es knistert in der linken Ohrmuschel.
Das ist kabelempfindlich, glaube ich, je nach Stellung.
Bist du sicher, dass du den Stecker richtig reingesteckt hast? Du hast das doch gerade erst angeschlossen.
Ich hab's und es hat einen Kabelmackler. Jetzt ist es offiziell. Manchmal geht es ja auch ganz aus. Tja, voll der Fehlstart.
Kaputt.
Scheiße. Ach, dann hab ich dir den falschen Kopfhörer gegeben. Dann musst du das Intro machen, Dennis. Ich hol mal mein Kopfhörer.
Ja, herzlich willkommen wieder auf unsere Höre in der Schweiz oder Österreich. An den Hörgerät.
Das ist Mobile Max, ne?
Das ist Mobile Max heute, genau. Zu meiner Linken hier ist, äh, Warte mal einen Moment. Hucke ohne Kopfhörer. Noch weiter links ist Roddy. Und wenn man noch weiter nach links geht, dann ist man schon wieder rechts und da ist der Tim. Tim, sag mal was. Dennis, das ist überfordert. Ja, allerdings. Ja, ich hab auch die Themen gerade gar nicht so im Kopf.
Beziehungsweise auf dem Bildschirm, was?
Auf dem Bildschirm auch nicht, nee. Nee, ich bin kein...
Kein themorientiertes Leben gewesen.
Kein Leader und kein Teacher.
Besser, Huckel. Ja, und jetzt noch ein bisschen leiser.
So, ist jetzt alles gut?
Machen wir später noch mal leiser.
So, gar nicht so einfach mit so einem knackigen Intro ranzuschmeißen, oder?
Voll super. Bestimmt. Hast du einen gehört, der sich beschwert hat?
Naja, ich begrüße auf jeden Fall alle sehr herzliche zur 85. Ausgabe der Internationalen Technologie Gala. Der Ort, an dem die Dinge final entschieden werden, ob es gut ist oder schlecht. Vier Jahre später wird dann beim Spiegel darüber berichtet. Und so läuft's.
Hab ich jetzt einen Hint verpasst? Und wer erklärt mir den jetzt?
Wir müssen mehr über Nokia reden.
Ihr meint die aktuelle heutige Titelseite, die denn, wenn unsere Hörer uns hören, gar nicht mehr da ist. Toll.
Wahrscheinlich.
Die Rückkehr der spanischen Grippe?
Irgendjemand hat sich darüber muckiert, dass sie jetzt wohl wieder ein schlechtes Quartal ablegen werden und dass sich irgendwie ihr komisches Lunia nicht verkauft. Unter anderem wohl deshalb, weil es gleich so serienmäßig mit einem Firmware-Bug daher kam. Also richtig schöner Fail gleich zum Start. Das Flagship-Produkt gleich ab in die Tüte.
Und an Ostern gelauncht, wie Dennis mir berichtete. Auch der perfekte Tag, um lange Schlangen vor Geschäften zu garantieren. Weil das Geschäft hat zu.
Gab es wenigstens ein Osterei dazu?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich finde das sowieso mal merkwürdig, wie so die...
Sehr unchristlich sowas.
Was ist unchristlich?
Ja, so ein Gerät, an Ostersonntag einzuführen.
Haben sie das für dich an Ostersonntag eingeführt? In den USA. Aber es kennt doch sowieso kein Mensch, Nokia in den USA. Ich meine, der Marktanteil von Nokia in den USA lag schon immer unter jenseits von Gut und Böse. Also die haben da einfach keinerlei Standing. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum sie jetzt ausgerechnet mit dieser Augenwache waren.
Du meinst, die haben extra den Ostersonntag genommen, damit keiner was merkt.
Damit die Leute nicht am gleichen Tag zurückbringen können.
Naja, das Lunia, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das noch mal was wird.
Ist doch ein toller Name.
Ich hab gehört, dass wir hier parallel zum Fußballspiel zwischen Bayern und Borussia Dortmund senden. Für die Leute, die sich jetzt erhofft haben, dass wir hier die...
Kannst du kurz erklären, was Fußball ist?
BVB ist Borussia Dortmund. Ja, du bist nicht so dein Sport, oder?
Nee, ich guck nur, wenn's wichtig ist.
Okay.
Also Viertelfinale.
Ja, wenn's spannend wird. Wenn damals Klaus Alochs irgendwie danebentritt und auf dem Spielfeld heulend zusammenbricht, dann ist Sport teuer, aber ansonsten. Kannst dich erinnern?
Ja, das heißt Ballspielverein.
Wenn die zusammenbrechen?
Der BVB heißt Ballspielverein.
Ist doch ein schöner Name.
Naja, auf jeden Fall werden wir keine aktuellen Stände durchgeben. Wir hatten das erwogen, aber leider haben sich die Stadionbetreiber nicht dazu durchregen lassen, den aktuellen Stand bei Mobamex auch gleichzeitig im Stadion durchzusagen und deswegen ist die Sache dann einfach gestorben.
Aber vielleicht hört jemand im Stadion jetzt geradezu, vielleicht sogar in der Stadionssprecherkabine und kann da noch was arrangieren.
Die haben uns gerade über den Stadion-Lautsprecher eng gespielt. Na gut, dann können wir ja das Thema Nokia damit auch schon wieder abschließen.
Ja, ich meine, wir sprechen seit vier Jahren, singen wir den Abgesang. Kann man den Abgesang singen? Ja, doch natürlich. Und ja, jetzt ist es ja langweilig auch, wenn es dann plötzlich, also nicht mal plötzlich, sondern...
Ja, aber ich frage mich, wer jetzt überhaupt noch mal irgendwie aus der Versenkung hervorkommt und mal irgendwas Überraschendes tut? Also ich meine, bitte welche?
Du hast Angst, dass dir die Gegner ausgehen.
Und dann Apple.
Das ist ein Dauerzustand seit Jahren.
Ja, nee, noch waren die ja da.
Wie hießen noch gleich die bahnbrechenden Produkteinführungen der letzten drei, vier Jahre?
Windows 8, also hier dieses Windows Mobile. Oder wie heißt das?
Ich bin übrigens eingeladen worden.
Ich hab schon gesehen.
Wozu denn?
Zum Windows 8 Premiere Club. Da kriegt man hier so ein Schächelchen. Dachte ich schon so obweier. Und dann ist da so ein Billo-Plasten-Armband drin. Mit so einem aufgelaserten Zahlen-Code.
Zeig ich mal. Sieht aber schon besonders aus.
Und dann so ein Vorgeschmack vom GUI. Nämlich so einen komischen Tefelchen.
Die haben hier irgendwie so ein Hotel angemietet hier in Berlin. Europas erstes Musikhotel. Ja genau. Begleiten Sie uns auf einer Tour durch die Welt der Windows 8 Metro-Style-Apps, entdecken Sie die Möglichkeiten von Visual Studio 11 und Expression Blend 5.
Expression Blend?
Kaffeesort oder wie?
Ja, ich hab auch das Gefühl. Vielleicht gehört das jetzt zu dieser Krups Kaffeemaschine, die ich gekauft habe. So einfach neue Sorten hier von diesem kleinen...
Ein Whisky.
Du meinst, das gibt's als Kapsel?
Lernen Sie von renommierten Design- und Technologiefachleuten. Verpassen Sie so nicht, welche Geschäftschancen und Businessmöglichkeiten Windows 8 mit sich bringt. Grauer Text, ja, hier so ein Brief irgendwie.
Zeig mir noch mal das Armband.
Du wirst ja nur meine Nummer abschreiben. Wie kannst du die konzentrieren? Hier, ich hol's euch mal aus diesem kleinen Kondom, in dem das so eingedingst ist. Ja, ist sehr exklusiv, Gummi. Also schon was Wertiges, ne?
Sieht mehr so aus, als wenn du tauchen gehst und sie dich dann anhand der Nummer identifizieren sollen, falls er dir wieder hochschreit.
Das ist jetzt ein Stück Gummi mit einem Stück Blech außenrum.
Ja, genau.
Ja, und nicht mal schick Alu gebürstet, sondern irgendwie...
Naja, Windows 8 halt.
Nicht mal USB dran.
Das muss dann halt da irgendwie...
Vorzeichen, wenn du rein willst.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung. Scheiße ist auch nur so...
Hättest du mal nicht aufgemacht.
Hättest du schon bei eBay verkaufen können.
Für jeden, der kommt und ob der nun Amband hat oder nicht.
Deswegen hat es ja auch sechs Stellen, weil von den maximal 99.000 oder wie viel können dann kommen? 999.000 kommen wahrscheinlich nur ein paar...
Welche Nummer hast du denn, genau? Du bist Nummer... Also 546.954.
Oh, jetzt kommen alle unter Tims Nummer rein.
Na toll, jetzt hast du meinen Code durchgesagt.
Nein, ich hab's verkehrt rumgelesen.
Haben sie einen 27b-6? Auf jeden Fall sagen sie einem auch gar nicht, wie lange das geht. Sondern das Ganze geht wohl zwei Tage lang an einer einzigartigen Location, eine unvergessliche Party.
Also wenn ich mal so kurz überlege, was ich lieber machen würde, da fällt mir so einiges an.
Ich frage mich jetzt, soll ich da hingehen?
Schick doch, Max, der geht doch mal in Sparsensachen.
Ja, war der nicht schon auf sowas? Der ist doch schon hirngebürstet worden, oder?
Der war schon bei Windows-Phone-Events bestimmt.
Keine Ahnung, kriegt man denn eine Windows-8-Lizenz dazu? Dann würde ich es machen, aber ansonsten.
Tja, keine Ahnung. Wann ist das? Ich hab's schon wieder vergessen.
Mai.
oder 9.
Also, äh...
Ich glaub ja nicht, dass sie mich da irgendwie groß beeindrucken können, aber vielleicht soll ich genau deswegen da hingehen. Ich geh einfach ohne Erwartung dahin, und dann guck ich mal, ob irgendwas toll ist.
Und dann nächste Woche...
Oh Gott, er voll konvertiert wieder zurück, genau.
Genau, dann präsentierst du hier dein Nokia Lumia 900.
Aber sag mal...
Wer bist du und was hast du mit Tim gemacht?
Also, wie war denn das jetzt nochmal genau dieser Deal eigentlich? Also Microsoft hat irgendwie die Mehrheit nur Nokia, die haben sie nicht ganz geschluckt oder was?
Die haben die überhaupt nicht geschluckt. Die haben einfach nur Verträge mit denen.
Ach so, die haben nur Verträge.
Die haben sie nicht gekauft.
Die haben sie einfach nur über den Tisch gezogen.
Also nicht so wie Google, die einfach gleich den ganzen Laden eingesackt haben, haben dies ein bisschen schlauer gemacht, damit es auch keinen Kartellfu und so weiter gibt. Einfach...
Ja, ich denke, die standen einfach mit dem Rücken zur Wand. Und Nokia hat sich dann einfach an jeden Deal eingelassen, was ja so schwierig jetzt auch nicht war, da ja ihr Chef ein ehemaliger Office-Manager war. Naja, so ist das halt.
Na gut. Ja, also das heißt, diese Nokia-Menschen, die können jetzt noch ein bisschen pleite gehen und vor sich hin sichen und darben und irgendwann, wenn kurz vor Licht aus ist, dann schluckt Microsoft die doch noch oder steckt nochmal eine Milliarde rein oder so.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht so richtig. Also, ich meine, Microsoft kann ja eigentlich kein Interesse daran haben, dass Nokia dem Bach runtergeht und ich frage mich, was letzten Endes, was Nokia jetzt eigentlich noch retten soll, weil eigentlich das Geschäft, von dem sie derzeit zehren, das ist definitiv nicht die Smartphones, sondern eben diese Featurephones, das geht halt Stück für Stück an Android verloren. Android ist halt das neue Featurephone. Und ja, und der Smartphone-Bereich ist halt teilweise Android und vor allem iOS. Und ich weiß nicht so richtig, was sie da jetzt noch antworten sollen. Jetzt haben sie keine OS mehr, jetzt hängen sie in der ganzen Softwareentwicklung an Windows dran und ich weiß nicht, habt ihr mit diesem Windows Phone schon mal ein bisschen rumgespielt? Also ich kann diese Begeisterung, die manche Leute von sich geben, nicht verstehen.
Sagen wir mal so, ich muss mal sagen, letztens stehe ich an der Ampel und sehe ein Plakat von dem neuen Sony Android-Telefon. Und ich gucke mir das Plakat an, das ist hübsch gestaltet, dann gucke ich mir das Interface an und denke mir, sieht das scheiße aus. Also wirklich, da sind nur ein paar Icons auf dem Screen und es sieht scheiße aus. Scheiß von, scheiß Icons, scheiß alles. Also richtig... Ja, also kickt mich überhaupt gar nicht. Und wenn ich dagegen halt so ein Lunea, Lumia, was auch immer in der Hand habe und da zumindest mal in der GUI irgendwie was Neues passiert, irgendwie das Auge so mal ein bisschen bespielt, sag ich mal, finde ich das tatsächlich attraktiver oder erstmal hübscher als jetzt diesen ganzen Endroll-Krempel. Ich hab's halt nicht lange benutzt. Ich kann hier überhaupt nichts. Also mein Eindruck war vom bisschen rumspielen, dieser Effekt, ach, ist ein bisschen neu und anders und sieht ja eigentlich ganz fancy aus, nutzt sich halt relativ schnell ab und wahrscheinlich ist die Usability von diesem Interface auch nicht so prickelnd. Aber jetzt so, wenn du ein Android und das nebeneinander hältst, dann macht das glaube ich schon fast sogar einen besseren Eindruck. Also irgendwie so ein bisschen polierter oder irgendwie schicker.
Es ist wenigstens fluffig. Also ich hatte es mal ausprobiert. Ich hab's nicht auf Anhieb verstanden, aber die Animationen waren flüssig, während bei Android ja beides nicht ist. Also man versteht es nicht und die Animationen sind nicht flüssig. Also das ist irgendwie so. Ansonsten dieses Gekache, ich find's ja hässlich, aber bitte.
Ja, aber es ist halt mal so ein Smartphone, was jetzt nicht irgendwie 0815, weil schon hier, wir haben jetzt das Konzept mit den Icons und so, haben wir alles jetzt schon tausendmal gesehen.
Ja, ist schon ganz niedlich. Zumindest ist es eine eigene Idee. Also das geht ja Android ja auch so ein bisschen ab. Aber so richtig überzeugend finde ich das nicht. Vor allen Dingen hat das halt auch so dieses Problem schwarz-weißer Icons. Das ist, also das habe ich auch bei diversen Programmen immer das Problem. Also gerade so dieses, diese Finder-Sidebar links, wo diese ganzen Orte drin sind, die jetzt alle grau in grau sind. Und man kann die nicht mehr unterscheiden. Und genau dieses Problem hat aber auch diese diese komische Kachel-Optik, die ja nur bunt mit weiß ist. Und irgendwie, das bietet dem Auge irgendwie keinen Widerstand. Das ist so, die sehen alle gleich aus, finde ich.
Die Punkte würde ich auch eins zu eins so teilen. Nicht, dass du trotzdem nichts persönlich auf jeden Fall ansprachst. Wie gesagt, so dieses Snappy, das irgendwie, das verhält sich einfach.
Das ist schon mal ein Schleck.
Und deswegen, ja, war wirklich, kommt ein Sony mit ihrem ersten Smartphone, machte so ein Plakat. Das sah einfach echt, also...
Was haben die irgendwie für einen Verlust im letzten Quartal jetzt, oder was ist das? Ja, 5 Milliarden oder so.
5 Milliarden?
Jaja, da ging es gerade richtig schlecht. Also der ganze Konzern, jetzt nicht nur die Phone-Sparte.
Die brauchen auch mal einen Steve Jobs jetzt.
Und die Phone-Sparte heißt ja jetzt überhaupt erst Sony. Also sie haben sich ja jetzt sozusagen das Ericsson daraus gekauft. Damals hatten sie sich ja mal verheißungsvoll zusammengetan. Aber der Sony Ericsson-Brand ist dead. Ist ein abgeflattertes Federvieh. Ja, aber wir sollten vielleicht mehr über Max reden, weil da ist ja, wie wir alle wissen, alles in Ordnung.
Ja, niemand.
Der Max wird zunehmend in Maße die Normalität. Jetzt auch mit Viren. Das ist schön, oder?
Das ist total super. Nee, das war ein Trojaner.
Richtig. Genau.
Und die gibt's doch schon immer.
Also, Macintosh immer noch virenfrei, aber... Na ja, gut, Trojaner hin, Trojaner her. Also, diese Variante, wovon reden wir jetzt überhaupt? Wir reden von diesem Flashback, der gar nicht neu ist, den es, glaube ich, seit September letzten Jahres gab in The Wild, der aber dann nur über den Umweg eines gefakten Flash-Installers daherkam. Hence the name. Und dann eben...
Ist eigentlich schon geil genug, oder? Also, ich meine, gerade einen Flash-Installer zu nehmen, nicht irgendeinen anderen Installer. Nein, Flash muss das natürlich sein.
Naja, weil ja der Mac serienmäßig halt ohne Flash kommt mittlerweile.
Ja, Steve, hättest du es mal gelassen, hier Flash rauszuwerfen.
Das hab ich auch so an einigen Stellen so gelesen, da der Mac das ja nicht hat.
Und dann alle Leute, die das nicht bei Sobi runtergeladen haben, sondern auf irgendeinem komischen Download-Seiten, haben sich den eingefangen. War selber schuld.
Naja, klar sind sie selber schuld. Aber ich frag mich, also diese Verbreitung von diesem Trojaner, also ich meine, wenn man sich den über eine Webseite einfängt, dann gilt das ja wohl nicht mehr als Trojaner. Ich meine, man surft auf irgendwas. Die neue Variante ist ja, sie nutzen eine Java-Lücke aus, dazu muss Java installiert sein.
Und zwar eine ältere Variante, aber es gab halt nur die ältere Variante, die hatte die Lücke.
Ja, bis vor kurzem.
Die Oracle wohl auch schon vor einem halben Jahr gefixt hat, aber Apple hat keine Update rausgebracht.
Ja.
Und die neuere Variante? Irgendwie sowas, ja. Also schon gut abgehangener Bug-Fix. Da hätten sie mal ein bisschen, ja, keine Ahnung, irgendwann hat Apple ja auch gesagt, also wir machen nichts mehr an Java, das muss Oracle machen. Und dann haben sie es irgendwie, naja, Oracle hat auch nichts gemacht und dann war die Lücke da draußen. Niemand hat sie gefixt, ich weiß es nicht.
Wie ist denn die Situation? Ich meine, mit 10-7, komme ich jetzt durcheinander? Ja, doch für 10-7 ist doch das Java, wie ist denn das? Das nächste Java wird ja von Oracle gemacht. Aber das aktuelle Java ist schon noch von Apple.
Irgendwie so, ja.
Das kommt auf jeden Fall.
Und es ist serienmäßig nicht mehr installiert, aber es ist serienmäßig eine Routine vorhanden, die es halt installiert, wenn du es haben willst. Das heißt, wenn ich auf eine Webseite gehe, die nach einem Java-Plugin fragt, oder wenn ich mir Software runtergeladen habe, die in Java geschrieben ist, dann kommt er hoch und sagt, ja, Java, will man? Und dann klickst du und dann installiert er und dann ist es da. Also das ist relativ seamless. Frage ich mich natürlich, wie häufig kommt das so vor? Ich habe einen konkreten Grund, warum ich bei mir Java habe. Ich habe genau eine Anwendung, für die ich es benötige. Gilt das für die meisten Leute?
Ich habe auch eine Anwendung.
Es gibt da eine schöne Anwendung, die ist Teil von Xcode, die man benutzt, um irgendwie außerhalb von Xcode Sachen zum iTunes-Store hochzuladen als Entwickler. Die ist auch in Java. Und die ist der Grund, warum es ein zweites Java-Update gab, weil nämlich der Bug-Fix diese Anwendung kaputt gemacht hat.
Deswegen kam ein Tag später diese 002-Variante vom letzten Java-Update?
Ja, das muss man nicht verstehen.
Irgendetwas ist kaputt hier. Irgendetwas funktioniert nicht. Aber ich wollte jetzt noch mal auf diese Infektionszahlen zu. Wir wollen mal davon ausgehen, dass diese erste Variante nicht weiter groß durchgeschlagen hat, weil so viele Leute jetzt nicht unbedingt auf einen falschen Flash-Installer gehen. Wenn irgendwas nach Flash schreit, klickst du im Browser, ja installier mal, und dann kommst du direkt bei Adobe raus und da wird dann irgendwie, dann wird es dir jetzt mal nicht besonders einfach gemacht, den richtigen Link zu finden. Das fand ich schon mal so absurd. Hast du das schon mal probiert, wie unintuitiv es ist? Also selbst wenn du sagst, ja guck mal nach dem Update, dann sagt er, ja es gibt eine neue Version und listet dir auf einer Seite auf, was die aktuellen Versionen sind. Nicht, dass er dir sagt, was gerade deine aktuelle Version ist, sondern nur weil diese Seite ist, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass du wahrscheinlich eine hast, die nicht so alt ist. Aber dann fehlt irgendwie so der große Button, wo drauf steht, und jetzt hier die neue Version laden, sondern da musst du im Sidebar wieder Flash-Installer raussuchen. Also sie machen es einem auch wirklich schwer. Und ich frage mich eigentlich auch ernsthaft, wie viele Leute installieren jetzt eigentlich Flash nach, die sich jetzt gerade neu ein Mac kaufen und die nicht eine alte Installation haben?
Na, es gibt so viele Browser-Games, glaube ich, die unter Flash laufen.
Das glaubt das Mann viele. Ich mach das. Ich muss das ja.
Aber diese Seite ist schon geil, wenn man da irgendwie durch die ganzen Windows durchscrollt, dann an diversen Linuxen vorbei, dann kommt noch Solaris und irgendwann kommt dann mal der Mac. Das ist irgendwie schon sehr geil.
Echt super. Ich hab ja letztens mir den Flash-Debug-Player mal installiert. Da war es nicht so eine lange Liste, aber den gibt es wahrscheinlich nur für Macs und Windows.
Jetzt gibt es also diese andere Variante, die sich über einen Drive-By-Download macht. Das heißt, du kommst auf eine Webseite und irgendwie schaffen sie es dir...
Über ein Java-Applet.
Über ein Java-Applet, ohne dass du irgendwas tun musst, dir Code zu installieren, der sich gleich ins Botnet einkriegt. Das ist natürlich schon ziemlich hardcore. Jetzt frag ich mich natürlich, wo sind diese Seiten? Wie viele Seiten sind das? Wieso kann das auf einmal 1% der Mac-Userbase ergreifen?
Wie kommst du auf 1%?
Das sind so die Hochrechnungen, die ich gelesen habe, von der Verbreitung von 600.000 Rechnern. Das heißt, relativ zu der Installed Base, von der man derzeit ausgehen kann.
60 Millionen.
Installed Base waren, glaube ich, was von 49 Millionen gelesen.
Also du kannst natürlich so ein bisschen...
Ein bisschen weniger als 1%.
Du kannst natürlich ein bisschen von dem Verbreitungsgebiet ausgehen. Also richtig eingeschlagen hat er ja nur in Amerika und so ein bisschen in Kanada. Und in allen anderen Ländern sind es nur sporadische Zahlen gewesen. Also es muss dann schon auch eine Seite gewesen sein, die vor allen Dingen...
Die waren nur in Kanada und USA abgerufen? Was soll das denn sein?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es nur für Kanadier und US-Amerikaner interessant ist. Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht war es die Steuerbehörde, sowas wie... Wie Elster Online für die USA, wo sie alle hingehen müssen.
Na ja, dann hätte man aber wahrscheinlich überhaupt keine Downloads aus anderen Ländern. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Also, ich finde in dieser ganzen Geschichte sind echt noch ganz schön viele Fragezeichen, weil ich mich jetzt halt wirklich frage, was an der Stelle... Also wer hat jetzt hier überhaupt Fehler gemacht? Meine Apple hat anscheinend Fehler gemacht, so wie sie es uns darstellt jetzt, weil sie haben ja, wie du so schön sagtest, kein Update rausgebracht.
Obwohl das ja schon lange bekannt ist.
Wobei man auch nicht weiß, ob das, keine Ahnung, so einfach gewesen ist, dieses Update an der Stelle rauszubringen. Ich weiß nicht, welcher Teil ist denn überhaupt betroffen?
Keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist halt schon angeblich ja sehr lange bekannt. Und in allen anderen OOS schon längst gefixt und gepatcht. Oder gibt schon lange ein Update dafür.
Also richtig schützen kann man sich davon nicht, weil kann ja Apple auch nichts dafür, wenn die bei Oracle verkacken. Aber Apple hätte natürlich schneller reagieren können und hätte zumindest dafür sorgen können, dass es nicht 600.000 infizierte Rechner sind, sondern halt keine Ahnung, ein paar Tausend halt oder so.
Interessantes Titbit am Rande, was ich heute gelesen habe. Irgendeine russische Security-Firma hat es irgendwie geschafft, den Command-and-Conquer-Server zu übernehmen und das Teil aufs eigene Netz umzuleiten. Und haben dann von ihrem Registrar, von ihrem Domain-Registrar die Frage gekriegt, ob denn das so stimmen würde. Sie hätten da eine Anfrage von Apple, dass sie bitteschön jetzt diesen Netblock mal löschen sollen. Da hat sich also offensichtlich Apple nicht die Mühe gemacht, mal zu gucken, wem das Zeug gehört.
Ist ja auch egal.
Also was dahinter steckt, ist, dass Apple jetzt auch, so wie Microsoft das ja auch schon seit langer Zeit macht, auch aktiv versucht gegen die konkret von dieser Flashback-Software kontaktierten Netze ranzugehen. Also das Botnetze, auch die Rechner, die dann infiziert sind, die kommunizieren natürlich nach außen. Und das, womit kommuniziert wird, das soll natürlich jetzt heruntergenommen werden.
Die kommunizieren deswegen, weil die wissen ja nach dem Installieren noch nicht, was sie genau machen sollen. Und die holen sich dann sozusagen ihre Commands irgendwie von woanders ab. Damit man die möglichst dynamisch einsetzen kann. Weil der Botnet-Pesitzer, der kann ja nicht alle 60.000 Rechner kennen oder 600.000 und den sagen, jetzt macht mal Folgendes, sondern die fragen den.
So läuft das ja.
Ja, beziehungsweise die Dienstleistungen, die er da anbietet, die muss er ja dann den Rechnern überhelfen. Was auch immer es ist, dann ist.
Tja, und was machen wir jetzt? Erstmal den Rechner checken. Panik, genau.
Naja, also Apple ist ja angeblich dabei, irgendwie ein Tool zu schreiben, das irgendwie das Ding findet und entfernt, wenn es denn da ist.
Also Tipp Nummer eins wäre für mich, wenn es noch nicht passiert ist, im Safari unter Security Java ausschalten. Das wäre ja schon mal Maßnahme Nummer eins, weil Java im Web hat irgendwie sowieso nichts zu suchen. Also außer für ganz krasse Ausnahmen, aber dann weiß man hoffentlich auch, wer der Urheber der krassen Ausnahme ist und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich habe Java immer aus dem Browser. So, und dann Schritt Nummer zwei. Ja, und dann Schritt Nummer zwei ist halt, dann gibt es hier von FS...
Stimmt, ich habe es auch aus.
Von FSegure gab es ja dann so einen Post auch, wo sie geschrieben haben, wie man prüfen kann, ob man betroffen ist. So, Schritt Nummer zwei kann man dann eben mal ausprobieren. Habt ihr den Link gerade? Ich habe den mal, ich poste den in den Chat. Und...
Es gab da auch noch so ein GitHub-Projekt, wo jemand da tatsächlich was geschrieben hat. Habe ich das jetzt hier auch? Nee, den habe ich jetzt nicht da.
Ja, auf jeden Fall sind da ja die Schritte drin, wie man dann das Ganze auch wieder los wird. Vielleicht. Und Schritt Nummer 3 könnte dann auch noch sein, sich sowas wie Little Snitch oder Hands-Off oder Xcode oder was man das noch für Projekte zu installieren. Denn witzigerweise hat ja dieser komische Trojaner dann, wenn irgendwelche komischen Pfade existiert, dann nichts mehr gemacht.
Ja, der hat sich da geweigert dann zu installieren, wenn man sowas hat.
Oder zum Beispiel dieses Packet-Peeper, das ist so ein räudiger Packet-Sniffer für OS X, glaube ich auch schon seit eh und je Abandonware. Und wenn der aber installiert ist, dann macht er auch nichts. Witzigerweise fehlt in der Liste Hands-Off. Also Little Snitch und Hands-Off machen ja mehr oder weniger das, oder sehr ähnliche Sachen, aber Hands-Off haben sie in der Liste vergessen. Das heißt, Leute, die so eine Personal Firewall am Laufen haben und gucken, was für Verbindungen rausgehen, die...
Die wollen halt nicht auffallen.
Ah, da hat einer das GitHub-Ding im Chat gepostet.
Na ja, vielleicht sind das Leute mit Expertise.
Oh, Developer.
Mit Ahnung.
Das kann natürlich sein, dass sie einfach sich nicht auf Rechnern befinden wollen, wo Developer sind, die so einen Plan haben. Das kann schon sein.
Das kann ich gut nachvollziehen.
Ja, das heißt, einfach Entwickler werden und schon...
Zur guten Seite.
Und schon ist alles super.
Genau, schon ist alles super. Wäre das gedacht.
Wo wir gerade bei Hands Off sind, da gibt es übrigens eine neue Version gerade. Nur so am Rande.
Kann dir irgendwas tolles.
Also bei Hands Off... Hands Off ist ja im Gegensatz zu Little Snitch, hat es schon ein paar coole Features mehr. Du kannst zum Beispiel Programmen verbieten, dass sie Files auf deine Festplatte schreiben. Also der macht sozusagen auch Sandboxing. Und kannst dann so ein bisschen fein granulierter schalten und walten. Und jetzt in der neuen Version haben sie im Prinzip... Also dieses große eine Feature ist, dass du jetzt Wildcards für alles Mögliche benutzen kannst. Weil üblicherweise ist es halt so... Es gibt dann immer so Rules und die... Also oder Hosts oder was auch immer, die immer leicht variieren. Und dann machst du halt tausende Rules für eigentlich den gleichen Use Case. Und das kannst du jetzt halt für Hostnames, File, Farts und Application Pairs halt machen. So, dass sie die neue Version... Aber ich benutze das seit ihr und jedem. Ich bin damit eigentlich total happy. Und das little Snitch, das ist ja so ähnlich wie bei Launchbar. Die machen ja seit... Machen ja immer ewig keine Updates. Und dann musst du da auch auf die Webseite gehen und das downloaden ohne Sparkle Share und dieser ganze Krämpel. Und bei Hands Off ist das alles so ein bisschen...
Ohne Sparkle.
Das ist auf jeden Fall mit Self-Updater. Ja, da gab es auch irgendwie eine neue Version. Deswegen, die scrollte gerade in meinem E-Mail-Programm durch.
Jaja, also diese Jungs von Metakine, die sind auf jeden Fall gut unterwegs.
Machen auch ganz viel anderen Kram. Den hab ich aber noch nie benutzt.
Nee, ich auch nicht, interessanterweise. Ja, ich weiß nicht, mich hat das irgendwie lange Zeit genervt, aber ich glaube, jetzt könnte ich auch mal wieder, zumindest für den Mobilrechner, mal wieder hier das mal installieren.
Na, das Coole ist halt auch, der fragt dich ja erstmal nach Presets und du kannst halt gleich beim ersten Check sagen, irgendwie Netzwerk darf er alles und Files darf er alles. Und dann nervt er dich halt bei gar nichts mehr. Und bei Programme, wo du dir nicht sicher bist, da kannst du halt sagen, naja, nee, ask mal lieber. Also er fragt dich halt immer, nie oder fragen. Und wenn du dann halt fragen gehst, dann bist du in diesem Little Snitch Mode, wo dann halt bei jedem Poop sozusagen dann noch so einen Dialog hochgeht, bis du die richtige Rule gefasst hast. Aber du kannst halt vorher in deinem Preset das auch gleich regeln. Und das finde ich eigentlich auch ganz schön.
Genau. Also auch das hätte euch oder könnte euch auch noch Ärger ersparen. Solltet ihr euch nochmal irgendwelche Botnetze einfangen.
Genau, zumindest weiß man dann, wenn dann plötzlich Connections aufgehen von irgendwelchen Programmen.
Ja, offensichtlich ist es ja so, dass man die Dinger nur installiert haben muss. Man muss sie gar nicht benutzen.
Aber wie gesagt, Hands-off fehlt ja nicht. Es war nur der Snitch bei ihm.
Ob das jetzt vollständig war, was da genannt wurde, weiß ich nicht. Ein paar interessante Links hier im Chat, die werden wir dann hoffentlich auch in den Shownotes wieder finden, wo man noch ruckklicken kann. Das Ganze auch in Deutsch. So. Ich hab leider den Teil noch nicht nachgehört. Ihr habt euch letztes Mal über diese Diskussion über Macup-Store-Upgrades unterhalten.
Na ja, was heißt Diskussion? Ich hatte das aufgebracht, dass dieser, na wie heißt er?
Will Schipley.
Will Schipley. Da einen länglichen Blogpost zugeschrieben hat, auch mit ein paar Zahlen und Kurven und so weiter. Ja, wie soll ich sagen? Also ich kenne eigentlich nur Entwickler, die dem ganz herzlich zustimmen würden. Ich meine für iOS ist es...
Was ist jetzt der Kontext gerade?
Also der Kontext ist, es gibt für App Store, egal ob Mac App Store oder iTunes Store, Apps gibt es keine Möglichkeiten, bezahltes Upgrade anzubieten. So von Version 1.0 auf 2.0 oder von 2.0 auf 3.0, sondern du hast nur die Chance, dass du entweder all deine Updates umsonst rausbringst oder aber, dass du ein komplett neues Programm machst und dann das alte irgendwie abschaltest, dann können die Leute das aber nicht mehr runterladen, wenn sie es nicht mehr haben beziehungsweise du kannst keine Bugfixes mehr eintüten oder du lässt es drin und musst dann oben reinschreiben. Nein, das nicht, wir haben jetzt eine neue Version, kauf das andere und trotzdem musst du das neue dann aber zum vollen Preis anbieten. Also wie man es dreht und wendet.
Und sie könnten ihre Daten halt nicht ins neue Programm mit rüber kriegen.
Ja, das kommt noch dazu. Genau. Also wie man es dreht und wendet, die ganze Situation ist total unangenehm, wenn du als Firma vom Geschäftsmodell her so lebst, dass du sagst, du bringst alle zwei Jahre irgendwie ein Update raus und deine Userbase, die existiert, kriegt dieses Update halt günstiger.
Kann man das mit In-App-Purchases machen?
Ja, im Prinzip natürlich schon, aber...
Dann kannst du insofern halt nicht machen, als dass du ja dann immer noch den alten Code hast, sozusagen.
Du meinst, verstehe.
Du musst ja dann immer sozusagen...
Du musst dann immer die Standard-Version anbieten und dann können Leute auch nicht...
Dann hast du immer wieder If, If, If, If, If...
Vor allen Dingen, du hast dann das Ding, dass du dann deine alte Version mit In-App-Purchase, also neuen Features per In-App-Purchase hast und hast dann die neue Version mit ohne In-App-Purchase oder aber du musst einfach, musst die alte Version quasi dann, weiß ich nicht, um den Preis das In-App-Purchase billiger machen, damit die Leute das dann erst das Programm kaufen, um dann das Upgrade auf die aktuelle Feature Set zu kaufen. Also wie man es dreht und wendet, ist es einfach völlig Unsinn.
Abgesehen davon gibt es ja derzeit noch nicht mal In-App-Purchase im Mac App Store. Ich meine, davon ist zwar auszugehen, dass das bald kommt, aber geben tut es das halt nicht.
Und insofern hat dieser Will Schipley, der ja dieses Delicious Library macht und gerne mal laute große Blogposts schreibt. In letzter Zeit relativ selten, aber wenn er einen schreibt, dann laut und groß. Der hat das mal angemahnt und jetzt besteht so eine gewisse Hoffnung, dass sich auf Grund dessen was bewegt.
Naja, also was mir halt so durch den Kopf ging, ist so auch die Frage, warum gibt es das nicht? Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, dass Apple noch nie von so was gehört hat. Ich denke, mit diesen Problemen sind sie irgendwie vertraut, weil sie haben ja auch selber so große Software-Pakete im Angebot.
Sie haben früher ihre Betriebssystem-Updates so verkauft.
Genau, und es gibt ja auch genug... Sie begleiten ja diesen Software-Markt ausreichend, als dass sie das Problem an sich kennen müssten. Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese Diskussion nicht schon auf dem Tisch lag. Also das ist bestimmt kein Thema gewesen. Das kann man mir nicht erzählen. Allein schon in dem Moment, wo man sich überhaupt über das Design eines Upstores Gedanken macht, ist das natürlich eine der Dinge. Wie gehen wir mit neuen Versionen um? Was mich persönlich eigentlich derzeit schon am meisten stört, unabhängig von dieser Upgrade-Preispolitik, ist so diese Problematik, dass wenn du halt deinen Upgrade, wenn du diesen Upgrade-Pfad auf Betriebssystem oder Geräte-Ebene nicht mitgehst, Programme, die du gekauft hast, irgendwann unter Umständen für dich nicht mehr einsetzbar sind, weil die sich ins neueste Modell hinein updaten, dann vielleicht auch, weil irgendwas in einer späteren Version deprecated ist, auch Features abschalten und irgendwann auch sagen, na deinen Betriebssystem unterstützen wir nicht mehr, was du noch hast. Stell dir mal vor, du bist jetzt auf dem Original iPhone. Und dann bist du halt nicht auf iOS 5. Und dann ist das Ding auf einmal von heute auf morgen kommt so ein kleines Mini-Update, Version 1.1.1. Und dann so, ahja, iOS 5 Support. Und das nächste was passiert ist, das Teil installiert sich eben nicht mehr auf deinem Gerät. Du hast überhaupt keine Möglichkeit, deiner iTunes, iCloud oder sonst wie ab Infrastruktur zu sagen. Das ist sozusagen hier gerade mein Set. Und wenn du dieses Update lädst, dann funktioniert deine Software nicht mehr. So mit dem Hinweis, naja, jetzt ja Backup machen können und so.
So ein Weg zurück gibt's bei Apple auch nicht, dass ich sage, ich will die Version von davor, weil die ging noch, weil sich der Developer nicht kümmert, gibt's nicht, ne?
Nee, sondern du musst dann auf dein eigenes Time Machine Backup, wenn du eins hast, zurückgreifen und das dann manuell da irgendwie rausprokeln. Und das ist natürlich kein zumutbarer Schritt. Also das ist für mich so ein bisschen verwoben generell mit diesem Versionsmanagement. Dass man also auch unabhängig von den Upgrades es schon sehr schwierig ist, da einen Überblick zu behalten. Die einzige Möglichkeit ist eigentlich immer, alle OS-Updates mitnehmen und immer das neueste Telefon kaufen. Das ist irgendwie die einzige Möglichkeit, wie du dem Herr werden kannst. Und das ist eigentlich insofern doof, als dass es einen eben auch schnell in so eine Denial-of-Service-Attacke reinbringt. Du machst ein Update, besten Gewissens, so hier, Bugfix, tralala, da irgendwas funktioniert jetzt besser und dann geht halt irgendwas nicht mehr. Das ist schon schwierig.
Na ja gut, also ich meine so gesehen, Apple lebt natürlich davon, dass sie dir neue Hardware verkaufen. Und so wie dein Betriebssystem irgendwann nicht mehr updatable ist auf gewisser Hardware und auch dein iOS nicht mehr updatable ist auf gewisser Hardware, musst du dir halt neue Hardware kaufen, um wieder aktuell zu sein.
Ja gut, damit kann ich erleben, wenn etwas nicht mehr updatable ist, aber wenn es sich updatet und dann funktioniert es nicht mehr, dann finde ich ist so ein Punkt erreicht, wo es mindestens fragwürdig wird. Was jetzt diese Paid Upgrades betrifft, ich verstehe natürlich diesen Punkt von dem Bishopley sehr gut. Das ist halt das Modell, was man so derzeit gewohnt ist.
Ja, aber es führt halt noch zu was anderem. Es führt halt dazu, dass du als Entwickler überhaupt nicht das Incentive hast, das Produkt als solches weiter zu pflegen. Also du hast eigentlich das Incentive zu sagen, ich mach jetzt das und jenes tolle, bunte Programm. Das kaufen dann möglichst viele. Ich bin möglichst weit oben im Upstore. Und sobald die Aufmerksamkeit weg ist, dann hau ich es weg und mach das nächste. Also du hast halt eigentlich ein Incentive dafür, Abandoned Wear zu schaffen. Weil du bekommst nichts mehr für deine Updates. Die sind halt irgendwie, das ist halt verlautern.
Ja gut, aber was angenommen ist, gäbe jetzt die Möglichkeit zu sagen, dieses Update gibt es nur gegen Geld. Was würde passieren? Dann könnte es natürlich sein, dass sie alle anfangen mit, ja hier, iOS 5 Support, nur 79 Cent. Maybe Apple doesn't want this. Also worüber ich so ein bisschen nachdenke ist, angenommen, Apple hat dieses Problem vollständig verstanden. Nehmen wir jetzt einfach nur mal an. Es kann ja auch sein, dass sie total delusional sind und sich gerade ums iPhone 7 kümmern und andere Sorgen haben oder irgendein Idiot da gerade querschlägt, irgendwas. Nehmen wir einfach mal nur an, die lesen so viel Schüppli, gucken sie sich an und sagen so, ja, reden wir schon seit Monaten drüber. Was schreibst du, Alter?
Sie kennen das Problem, sie wissen um das Problem und warum tun sie es trotzdem nicht?
Genau, sie haben das schon tausendmal diskutiert. Vielleicht. Also gehen wir mal davon aus, dass das Absicht ist. Dass es zumindest derzeit nicht nur eine Nachlässigkeit ist, dass sie das noch nicht geändert haben, sondern dass sie es auch bewusst nicht getan haben. Und zwar nicht unbedingt für alle Ewigkeit, sondern zumindest vorerst. Sowas wie, na, lass mal drei Jahre warten. Wie lange gibt es den App Store jetzt? Den iOS App Store gibt es seit 2008.
Sommer 2008.
Also wir haben jetzt vier Jahre iOS App Store und wir haben ein Jahr Mac App Store ungefähr. Also ist schon noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit. Sagen wir mal fünf Jahre. Dass sie sich gesagt haben, na ja, wir gucken mal jetzt, wie das läuft. Wie es läuft, wissen wir. Es läuft bombastisch. Leute werden zu Millionären. Was haben sie? 25 Milliarden Downloads. Also was auch immer das heißen mag, weil das ja die Updates theoretisch mit beinhaltet, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall geht weg wie geschnitten Brot und eigentlich sind alle glücklich. Und man merkt also, dass das Ökosystem, was jetzt unter den aktuellen Bedingungen sich da entwickelt, eins ist, wo jederzeit ein neuer Anbieter ins Feld kommen kann und in Hit landen kann. Während natürlich die alte Software-Welt auch so ein bisschen davon geprägt ist, alle haben Microsoft Office und warten jedes Jahr auf ihr Update. Und andere, also du bist ja in so einem Login eigentlich, man kann natürlich sagen, ich will das auch, weil ich will ja bei meiner Software bleiben, bei der ich immer geblieben bin und das Upgrade macht es mir halt auch leicht. Unter dieser aktuellen App Store-Situation ist es aber so ein bisschen so, irgendwann ist dein Produkt fertig. Du hast so, das Software-App ist ja auch so Mini-Applikation, die haben so die Likation abgeschlossen, abgeschnitten. Vorher waren es Applikationen und jetzt sind es nur noch Apps. Die ganze Likation, die ist irgendwie weg und macht das Ganze zu so einem kleinen Software-Häppchen. So ein Schnittchen.
Auf iOS würde ich dir da auch jederzeit zustimmen.
Ja, ist eigentlich auf MacOS derzeit auch schon ähnlich. Das sind halt so Programme, die dann, ich sage nicht, dass ich das gut finde, ich sage nur, so ist es, so stellt sich mir das gerade da. Du hast halt so Mini-Apps, da steckst du eine Weile deine Energie rein, dann hat diese Software auch ihre Schuldigkeit getan, kostet auch nur drei Dollar. Ich meine, das sind lächerliche Beträge, wenn man es mal vergleicht mit der Situation früher. So, und dann ist die halt irgendwann fertig und wenn du jetzt irgendwie was Neues machen willst, musst du dir halt was Neues ausdenken.
Ja, aber du machst doch schon deine Updates für das neue OS. Vielleicht neue Support für iCloud.
Solange du halt neue Verkäufe siehst, solange es neue Leute gibt, der Markt wächst ja derzeit auch immer noch sehr extrem.
Aber du meinst, wenn keine neuen Leute mehr kommen, dann sollte man die neuen Features, die man noch hat und die vielleicht für User cool wären, nicht einbauen, weil man ja von den alten Usern keine Kohle mehr kriegt. Also ich weiß auch nicht, was die Lösung ist, aber ist ja schon auch blöd für manche Developer, die da noch ein bisschen mehr machen wollen.
Aber es ist doch eigentlich, ist das ja auch nicht so, dass, also ist ja auch nicht so in der alten Welt. In der alten Welt ist es so, ich lad mir ja, was weiß ich, Transmit von Panic runter in Version 1, dann gibt es dafür eine Zahl kostenlose Updates mit Verbesserungen, Bugfixes, Arbitrary Performance Improvements und dann kommt irgendwann Transmit 2 raus, neue ab, kostet Geld auch und für Kunden, die schon Transmit 1 gekauft haben, gibt es dann halt den sportlichen Upgrade-Preis, aber ich lad mir trotzdem ein komplett neues Binary runter, eine komplett neue Applikation, das ist nicht so, dass Transmit 1 plötzlich Transmit 2 wird, sondern sie geben mir quasi einen Rabatt, weil ich schon Transmit 1 gekauft habe. Und mit dem Modell wär ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch denkbar, wenn jetzt irgendwie oder, weiß nicht, also es gibt auf jeden Fall...
Ja, aber es gibt ja nicht über den Upstore.
Ja, gibt's nicht, aber ich mein, so das, was ich jetzt da beschriebe, das gab's ja vorher in der alten Welt auch nicht so, dieses... Ich upgrade jetzt die eine App von 1 auf 2 in demselben Binary und so weiter.
Ja, aber du konntest halt so Sachen machen, also so rein vom Business-Modell konntest du Sachen machen wie, ich mach ne Grace Period, ich bring jetzt die Version 2 raus und wer in den letzten drei Monaten die 1 gekauft hat, kriegt die 2 umsonst. Damit die Leute nicht schreien, die gesagt haben, ich hab vor drei Tagen irgendwie die 1 gekauft, jetzt kommt ihr mit der 2 und wollt gleich wieder Geld von mir. Also solche Sachen kann ich halt machen in der alten Welt. Und ich kann halt auch sagen, ich hab jetzt so und so viele User da draußen und all diesen Usern kann ich jetzt auf einmal ein Update verkaufen. Und weil die aber schon Geld gezahlt haben und weil die halt nicht wieder komplett neu bezahlen wollen, aus gutem Grund, sag ich, die kriegen es halt für weniger. Was ist so, das ist so, das ist so diese, gut, vielleicht ist diese Denke auch verkrustet, dass man sagt so, hey, warum sollen die ein verbilligtes Update kriegen? Die sollen gefälligst für ein neues Programm wieder die volle Kohle zahlen.
Naja, ich sehe das halt auch so ein bisschen so wie Tim, dadurch, dass die Apps im Prinzip so sportbillig sind. Also, die ich mir damals noch Make-Ups gekauft hab, war immer irgendwie 40 Dollar oder irgendein so ein Kram, ja. Ich meine, davon kannst du dir jetzt 10 bis 20 Apps downloaden und dann irgendwie...
Ja, aber das sind ja nicht die gleichen Apps.
Aber auch im Make-App-Store sind sie ja jetzt im Wesentlichen... Also, ja, da gibt es auch Ausnahmen.
Die sind ein bisschen billiger geworden, aber es gibt natürlich die 40 Dollar Apps. Es gibt auch die 70 Dollar Apps noch im App-Store. Das gibt sie natürlich. Und für so eine App, die willst du natürlich nicht für den Preis wieder komplett neu zahlen.
Aber da könntest du ja im Prinzip, wenn du dann diese 10 Tage hast, nicht gesehen, dann kannst du bestimmt dir noch einen Refund von Apple geben lassen. Wenn du das oft genug machst, dann haben sie vielleicht auch ein Einsehen. Träumen.
Also, weißt du, das ist so... Und klar, für Apple lohnt sich das auch auf jeden Fall auch so dran zu gehen und zu sagen, ja, die sollen halt eine neue App machen, weil dann haben wir halt noch eine App mehr in unserem App-Store und können die große Zahl zur nächsten Keynote, die ist dann noch viel größer, die wir da in die Wand projizieren können, weil wir haben ja so unglaublich viele Apps. Und wie war das? Honeykamp hat nur 28. Oder wie viel war es?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Aber dann haben sie immer noch das Problem, dass du deine Daten von einer App nicht auf ein anderes rüberkriegst. Da müssten sie irgendwie was upgrade-mäßig anbieten, dass man sagen kann, diese Daten jetzt bitte in die neue App.
Also bei einer Mac-App wär's ja jetzt zumindest, solange es keine Sandbox gibt, jetzt nicht so ein Problem. Für eine iOS-App ist es natürlich was anderes.
Also an der Stelle könnte man jetzt wieder sagen, okay, jetzt könnte ich sogar einen technischen Grund sehen. Häufig ist es ja so, wir warten auf bestimmten Neuerungen. Denken wir so, warum hat Apple das noch nicht gemacht? Dann kommt es irgendwann. Und parallel dazu gibt es halt so ein neues OS-Release mit irgendeinem Major-Feature, wo man sieht so, ah, darauf haben sie gewartet, denn auf diese Technologie wollen sie aufbauen, damit sie das nicht alles ins Programm reinstecken, sondern sie warten halt, bis das Betriebssystem das kann. Und jetzt ist halt iCloud, meiner Meinung nach, das, wo die großen Weiterentwicklungen zu erwarten sind, was gerade solche Sachen betrifft. Wenn ich darüber nachdenke, übernehmen von Daten, von Programmen, wo ist das? iCloud, so. In dem Moment, wo es vielleicht diesen Mechanismus in iCloud gibt, vielleicht ist das eben eine der Sachen, die dann dazu führt, dass so ein Fortschritt kommt.
Momentan gibt es den Mechanismus aber nicht, weil auch in iCloud die Programme alle feinsäuberlich voneinander getrennt sind.
Ja, natürlich sind sie das jetzt.
Und du nicht die Möglichkeit hast, auf einen Container eines anderen Programmes zuzugreifen.
Ja, jetzt, das meine ich ja.
Aber man kann schon bei iOS das so coden und auch sich die App-IDs machen lassen, dass zum Beispiel zwei Apps sich Sachen aus der Keychain scheren können.
Ja, wahrscheinlich geht das auch mit iCloud. Das würde ich jetzt nicht hundertprozentig dort bestehen.
Wenn Sie das wollen, dass das so was geht, dann könnten Sie das über iCloud machen, aber wahrscheinlich müssten Sie es erst mal reinbauen. Aber natürlich haben Sie jetzt iCloud erst mal so gemacht, dass es erst mal so zu ist, wie es irgendwie geht. Es gibt vielleicht noch mal ein anderer. Der eine Gedanke ist jetzt quasi der, vielleicht haben Sie es einfach noch nicht gemacht, weil Sie an irgendeiner technischen Basis arbeiten, um das alles manageable zu machen. Was ja auch noch mit dazu gehört ist, mehrere Versionen verwalten und dann vielleicht auch so Unterversionen, auch um dieses von mir am Anfang angesprochene Problem zu adressieren. Ich habe hier eine Version, das ist so ein bisschen so ein Sackgassen, Zipfel und der wird jetzt noch supported für dieses alte iOS. Aber der wird jetzt nicht von einem anderen Update überschrieben, weil ich halt gesagt habe, dieses bitte... Forken. Ja, ich sag da mal, das will ich jetzt mit diesem iOS benutzen. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie sage ich das als User? Wie sage ich es meinem iTunes? Wie drücke ich das aus? Wie bildet sich so eine Versionsvielfalt im Store ab? Deshalb sagst du, such die ab, return, da ist das Icon, draufklicken, kaufen, fertig. Das ist simpel. Wenn du jetzt mehrere Major Releases hast, die da so nebeneinander parken und das eine ist dann noch für eine alte Version oder keine Ahnung, vielleicht ist es auch so, wenn du es neu kaufst, siehst du immer nur die neueste. Und wenn du aber die ältere noch hast, dann muss ja zumindest in deinem iTunes oder sonst wie, was hier gerade deine Apps visualisiert, deine Mac App Store Applikation auf dem Mac zum Beispiel, muss es dir ja auch irgendwie anzeigen, muss ja auch irgendwie klar machen, was da ist. Also das ist sicherlich nicht unmöglich, aber auch das macht es wieder komplizierter. Und auch das ist sicherlich etwas, woran Apple kein Interesse hat, dass dieser Kaufprozess schwierig ist.
Also diesen Kaufprozess selber sehe ich jetzt nicht so schwierig. Also wenn du es über das Telefon kaufst, dann ist es klar. Dann kriegst du die letzte Version, die auf dem Telefon läuft. Wenn du es über iTunes kaufst, dann könnte iTunes alle Versionen, alle letzten Versionen runterladen für alle Telefone, die iTunes verwaltet. Also du synchronisierst ja, back-up-t irgendeinen Scheiß und merkt sich ja sowieso, das ist das und das und das und das Telefon und dann...
Aber eigentlich will Apple das ja gar nicht. Eigentlich wollen sie ja, dass immer das The Latest and Greatest unterstützt wird. Also es ist einfach ein bisschen verfahren. Keine Ahnung, also ich würde nicht meine Hand dafür ins Feuer legen, dass das Problem sich bald löst. Noch nicht mal, ob es sich überhaupt löst. Andererseits, was ist jetzt mit so Programmen wie Final Cut Pro?
Na Final Cut Pro ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Das ist ein Apple Programm.
Deswegen ist es ja ein gutes Beispiel.
Nee, es ist nicht, weil Apple haut die Programme ja raus, um Rechner zu verkaufen. Sonst gäb's es auch unter Windows. Das ist ja, weißt du, ich meine, schau dir an, was sie momentan für Logic haben wollen. Das sind 250.
Dann könnten sie es aber auch kostenlos rausgeben.
Naja, das können sie ihren Aktionären nur schlecht verkaufen. Aber ich meine, guck dir an, Logic kostet 250 Euro. Und wenn du jetzt guckst... 150. Genau, 150 Euro. Das kostete vor, ich glaube, fünf Jahren. Also, als Apple eMagic gekauft hat, kostete Logic die Logic Suite 2000.
2000.
Genau, dann haben sie es auf 1000 halbiert.
Euro oder Mark?
Ich glaube Euro, ja. Dann haben sie es halbiert, dann haben sie es irgendwann auf 500 halbiert. Jetzt sind sie bei 150. Guck dir an, Ableton mit ihrem Live, da kostet das halt 600. Das ist seit Ewigkeiten dem Preis nicht gestiegen. Aber die haben auch nicht plötzlich irgendwie angefangen, das zu halbieren und zu halbieren und zu halbieren. Und es ist natürlich logisch, du kaufst für 150 Euro, kaufst du so ein Logic halt einfach so, wie es ist. Weil das ist wahrscheinlich sogar niedriger als der Update-Preis, den Ableton für live haben will. Und das ist für ein Programm dieser Mächtigkeit und dieser Größe, ist das einfach ein subventionierter Preis, also subventioniert zum Get No. Das ist kein realistischer Preis. Keine Softwarebude, die davon leben würde, so ein komplexes Programm zu verkaufen, könnte sich das leisten, das zu dem Preis anzubieten. Insofern ist es nicht realistisch. Das ist kein realistischer Preis, der ist subventioniert. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, Final Cut ist jetzt in einer neuen Version rausgekommen. Keine Ahnung, was kostet das jetzt?
Auch ein Zehntel von dem, was es vor ein paar Jahren gekostet hat.
Man kann sich ja, wenn man es gekauft hat, immer nicht angucken, was es kostet.
Ich hab es noch nicht gekauft. Final Cut kostet 239 Euro. Also ein Zehntel von dem, was es vor ein.
Premiere oder was es da gab? Das kostet doch keine... Kannst du knicken. Die müssen davon leben, dass sie diese Software bauen. Apple lebt nicht davon, dass sie Final Cut... Zumindest lebt das Final Cut Pro Team nicht davon, von dem Preis, zu dem Final Cut Pro verkauft wird. Können sie gar nicht. Die werden subventioniert. Weil Apple Hardware verkauft. Und deswegen hat Apple halt auch kein Incentive zu sagen, wir machen da jetzt bezahlte Updates. Weil das ist sowieso ein Preis, zu dem wäre ein Update schon halb geschenkt.
Also Premiere ist tatsächlich ziemlich billig. Kostet 179 Dollar.
Ist ein bisschen der da so sicher.
799, ok sorry.
799, das sind Dollar, aber naja gut.
Wenn ich mir so die Top 20 anschaue, im Mac-Up-Store, da ist Final Cut Pro auf Platz 20. Und der Preis auf Platz 20 im Mac-Up-Store, da kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass das nicht dieses Team finanziert. Also die machen da schon...
Ja gut, so gesehen natürlich schon. Shitload an Money machen die da. Weil sie es über die Masse wieder reinholen. Aber das liegt natürlich auch ein bisschen daran, dass sie halt so unglaublich gut exponiert sind durch den App-Store. Aber trotzdem, also...
Ja gut, aber das widerspricht jetzt so ein bisschen. Ich unterstelle mal, das Team bringt die Kohle rein, die es kostet. Locker. Wenn nicht sogar da noch ein ganz saftiger Gewinn dabei ist.
Zusammen mit einem Movie auf Platz 9?
Wie lange können sie... genau. Wie lange können sie... Wie lange werden sie das als anbieten? Heißt das jetzt, dass für die nächsten 10 Jahre Final Cut Pro X kostenlos ist für jeden, der jetzt einmal 240 Euro bezahlt hat?
Quatsch, wird es nicht sein. Natürlich nicht.
Und was passiert dann?
Dann wird es ein Final Cut Pro XX geben oder so. Das musst du dann neu kaufen. Und das andere verschwindet irgendwie, sagen wir, klanglos. So wie Apple das immer macht. Also ich meine, ja natürlich, was denkst du denn, was passiert?
Na ich sag, ich weiß nicht, was passiert. Ich sag, ich kann mir da einiges vorstellen. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass sie zu dem Zeitpunkt dann sagen, ja wir haben jetzt das iCloud App Version Management Tool, was irgendwie... Irgend so einen wunderbaren, super einfachen Default hat, so dass es für 99 Prozent der Leute genauso aussieht, wie jetzt auch. Ja, aber für die Leute, die einen spezialen Bedarf haben, dazu gehören übrigens auch solche Firmen. Also derzeit ist der ganze App Store nur für Individuals, aber wenn du jetzt eine Firma bist mit irgendwie 2000 Rechnern, wo du irgendwas deployen willst und so, dann musst du am App Store vorbei direkt mit Apple reden und deine eigenen Deals machst. Schulen, Universitäten. Ja, ich war neulich auf so einer Final Cut Pro Schulung, die Apple hier gemacht hat, wo sie mal so ein paar Features vorgestellt haben.
Es gibt für ein App Store aber eine Möglichkeit, so Schulendeals und mehr Deals für im App Store zu machen.
Ja, aber du musst da eigentlich schon auf die zugehen und irgendwie mit denen reden. Weil es nämlich auch keiner versteht, wie es ist.
Ich hab das versucht. Ich hab versucht, für die Uni Final Cut zu kaufen. Und hab da mit dem Support versucht zu telefonieren, keine Ahnung. Die haben dann gesagt, ja, gibt's nicht mehr irgendwelche Schuldeals. Muss halt einfach einen normalen Account anlegen, sich die Uni und dann kaufen. Und dann haben wir bei Kencom angerufen, was halt so einer der Standarddealer ist, neben HSD und so weiter und so fort. Und die meinten, ja, also wir könnten da was machen, dass sie im Prinzip verkaufen die dir dann Gutscheincodes, die du dann, also subventionierte Gutscheine, bla, bla, bla, die du dann im App Store einlösen kannst, um dann dir einen Final Cut dafür zu kaufen und so ein Kram.
Ich glaub, das ist noch nicht mal die Wahrheit. Ich krieg jetzt die Geschichte nicht mehr ganz zusammen. Er hat das so erklärt, aber in dem Moment war das gar nicht so mein Thema. Aber ich sag nur, das ist halt derzeit nicht gelöst. Diese ganze App Store-Geschichte ist auf Individuals ausgelegt, aber Organisationen sind nicht in der Lage, hier irgendwas zu verstehen. Und auch das hat was mit Versionen und Seat Management und Lizenzen etc. zu tun. Also da ist ohnehin noch einiges zu tun. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, ob sie daran arbeiten. Aber ich könnte ganz gut verstehen, dass eben diese ganze Geschichte auch dann eben wieder mit Upgrades oder mit Lizenzen-Erweiterungen etc. Also es ist ja verschiedene Fragen, dass du sagst, ich schieb hier nochmal zusätzlich Geld rein für dieses Produkt, um das irgendwie in einer bestimmten Anzahl zu deployen. Dass das unter Umständen eben mit solchen Upgrades auch zusammenhängt und dass sie da einfach an einer großen Solution arbeiten. Aber ich bin wirklich, ich bin wirklich...
Du denkst, wenn sie an einer großen Solution arbeiten.
Ey, ich seh grad hier in dieser Top 20, da ist auch Duke Nukem Forever drin. Ja, aber Mac App Store, Duke Nukem Forever und hier dieses komische...
Ja, das gibt's schon eine Weile...
.Rage, gibt's ja da auch dieses Rage-Container. Ja, schon lange. Ich hab lange nicht mehr in diesen App Store reingeguckt.
Total der Wahnsinn.
Ja, ich mein, hier auch ein Programm, was mir da eingefallen ist, ist ja auch dieses... Wie heißt das? Es heißt... Nee, Pixelmator, ne? Die hatten ja auch dann so ein ewig lange getrommelt für die App Store-Version und dann irgendwie haben sich ja alle die Version 2 gekauft, damit die dann billiger ist und so und im App Store. Und wie sie die dann weiter upgraden, weil die wollen garantiert dann auch nochmal eine Extra-Markt machen, wenn sie dann auf Pixelmater 3 gehen. Das, ja.
Da müssen sie sich mal einfallen lassen.
Den gemolten Thema ist durch.
Ist es.
So, was noch passiert? Nicht so viel.
Thank you for coming.
Hab ja hier letztens, also ich als alter Adventure-Spiele-Fan, ich bin jetzt, das ist überhaupt keine News, weil sie jetzt erzählt, die meisten werden das wahrscheinlich schon längst gehört und gesehen und vielleicht sogar Geld dafür ausgegeben haben, aber ich fand es trotzdem ganz cool. Nachdem ich ja hier berichtet habe, wie ich auf dem iPad Monkey Island 1 und 2 nochmal durchgespielt habe, voller Begeisterung und Machinarium und wie sie nicht alle heißen. Dann dachte ich ja noch, okay, jetzt wäre es ja eigentlich geil, wenn Day of the Tentacle nochmal so als Special Edition fürs iPad rauskommen würde oder sowas wie Grim Fandango oder die anderen LucasArts Adventures, hätte ich ja großen Bock drauf. Und dann so ein bisschen googeln, bin ich ja darauf gestoßen, dass dieser Tim Schäfer und dieser Ron Hubbard, also nee, nicht Hubbard, das war der Scientologe, aber ich glaube, der heißt so ähnlich, die halt bei LucasArts diese ganzen Adventures gemacht haben, dass sie ja ein eigenes Studio mittlerweile haben und auf Kickstarter ein Projekt gestartet haben. Hey, gib uns mal 300.000 Dollar, dann machen wir ein neues Adventure, komplett independent. Dann hatten die innerhalb von einer Woche 3 Millionen statt 300.000?
Ja, die waren die ersten, die die Million markierten. Das hatten wir alles schon in der Sendung.
Da war ich nicht da wahrscheinlich, ne?
Wahrscheinlich.
Voll geil.
Dieses Kickstarter hat das gut.
Die ersten, die Millionen hatten, und danach wurden sie aber auch gleich getoppt von diesen Typen, die das iPhone-Doc... Die ersten, die halt eine Million durchgedienst haben. Und danach wurden sie ja von diesem iPhone-Doc-Maker gleich nochmal überholt.
Ich sagte ja, irgendwann diese Publisher, die werden alle überflüssig. Das ist ganz großartig, wird das. Alles direkt zum Endkunden.
Ohne Apple?
Wieso? Nee. Ich krieg doch jetzt noch Spiele auch ohne Apple auf meinem Rechner installiert.
Ja, jetzt noch. Weil nicht mehr.
Wenn es nicht mehr so ist, höre ich auf. Mit diesem Mac. Ja, kannst du meine Words marken.
Wir reden da nochmal drüber.
Das wird nicht passieren. Doch.
Diese Jahrzehnte noch. Aber locker.
Auf keinen Fall. Aber sowas von... Und meine Musik krieg ich auch nur noch von Apple in meinen Filmen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich.
Das ist wahrscheinlich oder genauso sicher wie Software?
Was ich ja wirklich interessant finde, wo du jetzt gerade hier...
Jetzt lass uns doch auch mal ein bisschen anzicken. Nicht nur immer du und Max.
Ich muss dann aber auch dazwischen. Ich wollte mal so ein bisschen in die Zeit blicken und feststellen, dass durch diese ganzen... Also vor allem durch den iOS-Upstor und vielleicht jetzt auch durch den Mac-Upstor und vielleicht auch generell durch alle kommenden Upstores, die noch so hochkommen. Es ist erstaunlich, dass man heutzutage als Software-Entwickler auch wirklich in zunehmendem Maße wirklich so eine One-Man-Company sein kann und trotzdem erfolgreich sein. Ich meine, man könnte schon immer selbstständig sein als Programmierer, aber dann bist du dann meistens doch so ein bisschen der Coding-Büttel für ein oder zwei, drei Buden, die dich halt irgendwie regelmäßig engagieren, weil du irgendwie der Spitzi bist oder weil sie eh keinen Bock haben, dich anzustellen oder so als frei ausbeutbarer Freischaffen da missbraucht wirst. Aber am Ende irgendwie von deinem ganzen Code und deinem ganzen Erfolg, den du potenziell mit der Software hast, auch nichts hast. Und warum nicht? Weil natürlich dieses ganze Kunden-Suchen und Kundenpflegen und Billing und tralala, der ganze Scheiß, nichts ist, was einen irgendwie groß interessiert, wenn man programmiert.
Das gab es aber vorher auch schon. Vor Jahren hast du ja schon bei Carghi irgendwie deine Shareware-Software kurz machen können und so weiter. Es war mehr Aufwand, dass du auf jeden Fall, na gut, Support hast du so auch. Du hattest vorher den Vorteil, dass es nicht so viele waren und dass du es einfacher hattest, irgendwie gehört zu werden. Das war in dem Max-Shareware-Markt, da war es relativ einfach bekannt zu werden.
Ja gut, aber die Umsatzzahlen sind natürlich jetzt ganz andere.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Jetzt hast du einfach Millionen an potentiellen Kunden, die wirklich nur zwei, drei Tabs von dir entfernt sind, ohne dich vielleicht jemals vorher gekannt zu haben.
Aber es geht auch ohne. Siehe Minecraft zum Beispiel.
Ja, es gibt immer so die Ausnahmen, die aus welchen Gründen auch immer irgendwie erfolgreich sind, die gab es ja schon immer. Aber jetzt würde ich sogar fast sagen, es ist schon so normal. Ich meine, wenn ich jetzt so überlege, ich kann coden, ich habe eine Idee für ein Spiel, dann mache ich das mal so. Und du kannst dich eigentlich zu 99% auf deine Software konzentrieren und der Rest wird dir mehr oder weniger abgenommen. Du zahlst natürlich da deine Transzemen, gar keine Frage. Trotzdem ist das halt einfach möglich. Und warum ich das erwähne, ist, dass ich so eine Hoffnung habe, dass das einfach auch die Software verbessert. Weil Coder Zeit haben, das zu tun, was sie am besten tun können, nämlich Coden. Sie konzentrieren sich auf diese Software und können einfach ganz andere Zyklen machen. Und das findet ja eigentlich auch schon statt.
Du musst aber viel stärker inzwischen mit Grafikern zusammenarbeiten und mit Designern und so weiter. Um gut auszusehen. Diese App Store hat halt auch sehr stark dieses Mein Programm tut zwar nicht viel, aber es sieht gut aus, Art von App befördert. Insofern hast du halt auch dann immer wieder Apps, wo du denen halt auch ansiehst, dass sie von einem Designer gemacht sind.
Ich hab ja Gerüchte gehört, da gibt es so eine Bude, die haben 12 Mann oder was und die nehmen nicht mal Geld ein und die wurden für eine Milliarde gekauft.
Sowas gibt es.
Der App Store macht es möglich. Aber die können wenigstens auch Fotos schlecht aussehen lassen.
Das war auch ein geiler Tweet dazu, dass Instagram irgendwie alle Errungenschaften an den Kodak die letzten Jahrzehnte gearbeitet hat, um die Bildqualität zu verbessern, sozusagen, dass Instagram das alles wieder rückgängig gemacht hat.
Damit erfolgreich sind.
Damit erfolgreich sind, ja. Alle komischen...
Ja, also Instagram wurde gekauft von Facebook.
Ja.
Haben sich kaufen lassen. Das war wohl auch nicht der erste Anlauf, sondern die haben es wohl schon vorher mal probiert.
Na 30 Millionen Adressbücher, die sie jetzt einscannen können.
Bitte?
30 Millionen Adressbücher, die sie jetzt einscannen können.
Die sie wahrscheinlich schon haben. Tja, ich weiß nicht, nutzt einer von euch Instagram?
Nee.
Also sporadisch hab ich's benutzt.
Wofür?
Um Fotos zu posten. Also ich hab angemacht, dass es auch auf Twitter gepostet wird.
Ich meine, um Bilder auf Twitter zu posten, das geht ja auch.
Naja, aber du hast halt diese komischen tollen Artifati-Effekte dabei.
Diese Filter halt.
Diese Rumgefilter und dieses... Du kannst halt, wenn du das Bild gestalten willst und willst mal ein Bild posten, was irgendwie halt künstlerisch aussehen soll, dann kannst du halt Instagram benutzen. Dann ist es auch gleich rechteckig, also quadratisch und so. Also es ist halt eine andere Art, ein Bild zu posten, als einfach nur zu sagen, ich mach jetzt einen Tweet-Pick.
So ein bisschen ist eigentlich, Instagram ist so die digitale Nachkommenschaft der lomografischen Gesellschaft.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Das war so ein bisschen mein Eindruck, als ich das alles gesehen habe. Also erst mal irgendwie so diesen Lomo-Look, wo es ja auch so eine Community gibt, die aber eben viel kleiner ist, die sich auch so begeistert immer wieder um diese schäbigen Fotos geschart hat, so dass Instagram das jetzt im Prinzip abgeholt hat, dieses Potenzial, was da irgendwie den Leuten steckt.
Ich frage mich, wie viel ätzende Gülle Tim noch über Instagram auskippen wird jetzt.
Ich hab da ehrlich gesagt, nee, ich hab da gar nichts gegen. Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen schäbiger Look, oder? Ich meine, okay, man kann auch sagen, es sieht hübsch aus oder so.
Vintage ist das Wort.
Naja, es ist halt ein bisschen angeschrabbelt und komische Fotos. Ich hab's eh nicht so mit Fotos. Ich drück mir eine Kamera in die Hand, lass mich auf Weltreise gehen und ich hab dann 20 Fotos gemacht.
Von alten Computern.
Ja, so, weil ich einfach, ich hab keine Automatik.
20 Fotos gemacht, aber 100 Podcasts aufgenommen.
Ja, weil ich bin halt mehr so Hörensagen.
Hörensagen.
Ich bin mehr so vom Hörensagen. Und dieses Visuelle, mich tangiert ja auch Video nicht. Weder machen noch, also gucken ist was anderes, aber so dieses in Bildsprache sprechen ist nicht so drin bei mir. Das ist jetzt aber einfach eine ganz persönliche Präung.
Ab und zu hab ich da schon mal Lust zu, aber es ist jetzt irgendwie gut. Ich find's jetzt keinen Verlust, dass Instagram jetzt weg ist.
Ich meine, was ich ja starr...
Ist ja auch nicht weg.
Ist nicht weg.
Bei Facebook.
Das wird ja auch bleiben. Ich meine, Facebook wollte letzten Endes nur verhindern, dass ihnen keine Konkurrenz entsteht.
Ich frage mich, ob ich jetzt über Instagram durch die Hintertür irgendwie zu einem Facebook-Account komme.
Über kurz oder lang steht das natürlich zu befürchten.
Ich hab ihn nicht freigeschaltet, Max.
Genau. Nee, ich denke, das war einfach eine Maßnahme. Sie wollten, ich meine, vielleicht machen sie da jetzt auch so ein bisschen Talent-Aquise dadurch. Vielleicht wollen sie halt auch Features übernehmen. Vielleicht wollen sie sich mal eine ordentliche iOS abzulegen.
Vielleicht wollten sie auch nur die Userbase haben, die angeblich sehr, sehr groß ist.
Ich glaube, ihnen lag mehr daran, dass niemand anderes diese Userbase hat. Weil Instagram war einfach der Prototyp eines erfolgreichen sozialen Netzwerks. Auch wenn, sagen wir mal, die Interaktion sehr spezifisch war. Aber die Leute waren da und die Leute haben es regelmäßig benutzt. Und sie haben es vor allem von ihrem iPhone aus benutzt. Womit es eben, wie sagt man so schön, immer da ist. Also der Weg dahin, dort sich zu versenken, ist kurz. In dem Moment, wo Instagram sich für andere Kommunikationsformen geöffnet hätte, oder es vielleicht auch noch tun wird, so bleiben die Leute dann da und würden potenziell vielleicht dasselbe tun, was sie sonst auf Facebook tun würden. Und in dem Moment ist es für Facebook halt ein Konkurrent. Und ich denke, das haben sie verstanden. Und bevor Google kommt und irgendwie das zu Gründe richtet, richten sie es lieber selber zu Gründe.
Die müssen da echt richtig gut verhandelt haben, oder? Also, ich meine, eine Milliarde, die gibt es seit wann? Ende 2010, oder was stand da?
Den Laden gibt es nie langer.
Also, finde ich eine Milliarde für so eine 16-Mann-Bude, wie viele auch immer das jetzt genau sind, für die null Einnahmen haben, ja, finde ich schon echt. Also, Respekt, Alter.
Schön fand ich diesen iMessage-Chat, den irgendeiner auf Twitter gepostet hat, mit seiner zwölfjährigen Tochter, glaube ich, die da meinte, oh nein, jetzt haben die Instagram getauscht, gekauft und das ist ja furchtbar. Und der Typ so zu seiner Tochter, hä, wieso, was ist denn das Problem? Ja, Facebook ist nur für alte Leute und Instagram ist irgendwie...
Jetzt kommen die alten Leute zu uns. Facebook ist für alte Leute, das musst du dir mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Musst du dir mal reinzern, ja?
Du bist da nicht, weil da so viele junge Leute sind. Du bist alt, Dennis.
Da ist jeder Arsch und sein Bruder, wie man so schon sagt.
Die Grenze verläuft nicht zwischen jung und alt.
Also mein Facebook-Status ist einfach, ich weiß immer noch nicht, wofür ich es benutzen will. Ja, bei Twitter ist mir der Nutzen einfach sofort klar gewesen.
Und bei Facebook?
Ist der gleiche Nutzen bei Facebook eigentlich oder nicht? Was ist denn dein Nutzen bei Twitter? Sachen zu posten, die möglichst viele Leute lesen. Was machen die denn bei Facebook? Die lesen sich gegenseitig.
Da kannst du halt auch Events organisieren und Gruppen machen.
Machen die auch alle gar nicht.
Doch, machen die alle.
Man muss doch nicht. Alle machen einen Teil. Der meiste Teil ist doch auch nur am Lesen so Konsumer.
Das ist ganz viel.
Ihr wollt mir jetzt sagen, Facebook ist scheiße, weil die Leute nutzen das im Gegensatz zu Twitter, wo sie alle nur konsumierten?
Also ich sag's mal andersrum. Facebook ist toll. Weil Facebook ist das Internet, was alle verstehen. Da musst du nicht deinen Mail-Client aufsetzen und eine Pfade einstellen und weißt nicht warum.
Instant Messenger installieren und...
Ja, genau. Und wohin hat das den jetzt eigentlich geschickt und wie heißt denn der und was für ein Nick ist das und wie ich kann deine E-Mail-Adresse nicht in das Telefon angeben und kann deine Telefonnummer nicht in mein E-Mail angeben.
Im Prinzip ist das so wie Computer von AOL, diese Oberflächen von früher, dieses Internet in der Box.
Facebook ist das AOL der Neuzeit und das sag ich noch nicht mal als negativ.
Und warum benutzt du da keinen Facebook, um deine Sendung zu announced und so weiter?
Weil mir immer noch nicht so richtig klar ist, wer sich da tummelt. Probier es aus. Ja, ich könnte es ausprobieren, aber ich bin völlig total abgeschreckt von diesem ganzen Freundscheiß. Also das geht mir einfach völlig auf den Senkel.
Da kriegst du ja nichts von mit.
Follower ist halt einfach so ein asymmetrisches Modell.
Das haben wir übrigens auch in dieser Sendung schon bestimmt 23 Mal erklärt.
Aber das ist für mich der entscheidende Punkt.
Follower heißt Maul halten. Ich glaube die Sendung ist sogar so.
Bei Facebook ist es halt Freunde. Jetzt könnte ich die natürlich alle so wegignorieren und nur darauf setzen, dass ich da irgendwie subscribe. Dann habe ich dann irgendwann mal so eine Seite aufgesetzt. Und das erste, was ich festgestellt habe, ist, wenn ich die einmal eingerichtet habe, kann ich sie danach nicht mehr umbenennen. Da war dann sofort meine, also das entsprach einfach nicht meiner Erwartungswelt. Wie sich dieses, also das hat sich einfach noch nie, wenn ich mich mehr als fünf Minuten damit beschäftigt habe, hat es sich noch nie so verhalten, wie ich es erwartet habe. Das ist wirklich komisch. Und ich blicke immer nicht durch, wo ich bin und so.
Das ist völlig krass.
Und dann weiß ich halt nicht, wo kommen diese ganzen Nachrichten her, die ich da sehe? Ich hab kein Gefühl dafür, wer mich empfängt, wenn ich da sende.
Aber mittlerweile kann man das tatsächlich auch so pro Post, eigentlich dann immer so, kannst du sagen, wer soll denn das jetzt alles sehen?
Viel zu anstrengend. Das ist ja wie mit diesem Circle-Scheiß. Das ist noch bekloppter.
Und dann die Pinwand. Da gab es jetzt die erste Abmahnung.
Was?
Da gab es eine Abmahnung wegen einem Bild, dass jemand anderes jemandem an die Pinwand geheftet hat und derjenige, der das Bild bekommen hat, wurde abgemahnt.
Können wir eigentlich diesen Fitte Maus im Chat kicken? Der repeatet sich da seit einer Stunde schon und gabelt da nur Blödsinn rein.
Fitte?
Fitte.
Und schreiben kann er auch nicht.
Und schreiben kann er auch nicht, ja.
Ja, keine Ahnung, vielleicht hängt sein Client oder so.
Nee, der ist schon departed und auch wieder reingejoint und...
Warte, ignoriert jetzt, ja. Wir lesen dich nicht.
Für alle? Ich will kicken. Ja, anyway, also Facebook, Schmaysburg, Kaya.
Ah, da kommt ja auch schon der Link von Herrn Taggart.
Kann man machen, kann man ausleihen lassen. Das benutzen halt viele und machen da Umfragen und organisieren Events und was nicht alles.
Ja, so viel dazu.
Mal wieder eine kurze Twitter-Facebook-Abhandlung.
Also sollte irgendjemand von euch der Meinung sein, er wäre in der Lage mir Facebook näher zu bringen, bitteschön, dann höre ich mir das vor.
Ach nee, sag doch so was nicht, Tim.
Doch.
Jetzt kriegst du das wieder.
Dann lass doch einfach die Hörer für dich die Facebook-Seite pflegen und dann sehen wir ja, wenn das dann voll abgeht.
Ich meine, vielleicht gibt es ja einen Aspekt, den ich total übersehen habe. Mir wird ja häufig Ignoranz vorgeworfen. Ich streite das ja noch nicht mal ab. Ich bin da auch in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen ignorant, aber ich bin halt einfach dadurch einfach verstört, dass dieses Facebook sich einfach immer vollständig entgegen meiner Erwartungshaltung verhält.
Aber so eine Ignoranz ist auch wichtig in der heutigen Informationsgesellschaft. Ja, genauso wie eine gesunde Abwehrreaktion gegenüber Meetings.
Du musstest nur Filterwappel nennen.
Oder der antrainierte Filter für deine Mail-Inbox. Also manche Mails braucht man einfach nicht lesen.
Oder für Umfragenanrufe.
Ja, irgendwie so das.
Man muss nicht immer nett sein.
Ja, ist schon alles ok so.
Ach, der Commodore Gründer und später zu Atari Flüchter.
Genau der.
Die Sau, der Verräter.
So ein Jobs-Mini.
Was hab ich gelesen, als er versucht hat, seine Söhne irgendwie im Board zu installieren, haben sie ihn rausgeschmissen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das stimmt, aber...
Ich weiß auch nicht so ganz genau, was der Grund war, dass sie ihn rausgeschmissen haben. Aber ich hab ihn mal kennengelernt.
Ja, hab ihn mal kennengelernt.
Das war echt eine coole Story. Und zwar war ich ja damals Atari Fanboy. ST Ist jetzt schon sehr übertrieben, Fanboy zu sagen. Weil ich hatte halt einen, weil ich nicht auf den Amiga warten wollte und C64 war mir damals schon zu alt. Ja, C64 hat sich irgendwie durchgespielt und Commodore wollte halt Amiga, Amiga und haben das jahrelang angekündigt. Amiga, Amiga, aber es kam nicht. Und dann dauerte noch ein Jahr, noch ein Jahr, noch ein Jahr und dann kam der Atari ST raus.
Der war kurz vorher ja.
520 ST, genau. Und dann, wie das immer so ist, so Freunde kaufen sich den auch und dann kauft man halt das, was die Freunde kaufen. Lalalala. Und dann hatte ich halt dieses Teil auf dem Tisch stehen, weil war ja mit Maus und... Atari ST Atari ST ist eigentlich ein scheiß Computer gewesen. Das kann man echt nicht anders sagen. Also dieses Jam, das war alles so ein schlechter...
Die diagonalen Funktionstasten, die seh ich hier gerade.
Ja, Mac-Simulation mit DOS-Simulation darunter. Also tatsächlich hieß ja auch das Core OS von dem Atari, hieß ja TOS-Tremille Operating System. Und es verhielt sich halt auch wie DOS. Also es war halt so...
Achso, ich dachte mit Tremille.
Ja, so 8.3 Dateinamen und so. Das war doch richtig super.
Trotzdem, es war halt so der 16-Bit-Computer und der hatte viel RAM und es gab halt auch ein paar interessante Anwendungen. Und auch wenn das nicht so mein Ding war, hat es ja der Atari es auch geschafft damals so eine komplett neue Generation von Software, über die wir hier auch schon häufig gesprochen haben, heranzuziehen, nämlich im Prinzip die moderne Musikkompositionssoftware ist einfach mit dem Atari gestartet worden, weil sie einfach diesen genialen, diese geniale Idee hatten eine MIDI-Schnittstelle einzubauen. Hätte das mal der Amiga gemacht?
Man konnte direkt diese runden DIN-Kabel da reinstecken und hatte MIDI.
Und hätten sie das in den Amiga mit reingehauen, was wäre das für eine irre Kiste geworden? Ich glaube, die hätten dem Atari die Karten gelegt innerhalb von kürzester Zeit.
Naja, Amiga hatte noch ein zweites Problem, meiner Meinung nach, und zwar das war dieser Monitor, der halt irgendwie, also an den Atari ST konnte man ja diesen hochauflösenden schwarz-weiß-Monitor an.
Der 70-70-Hertz hatte und deswegen firmafrei war.
Und relativ schönes, ruhiges Bild hatte. Und bei dem Amiga musstest du irgendwie so einen normalen Fernsehstandard-basierten Monitor anschließen. Ja, genau. Das war im Prinzip ein Fernseher ohne HF. Also du konntest damit keinen Fernsehempfang. Aber alles andere war ein Fernseher an dem Ding. Und das hast du einfach gesehen. Gut, die Bildröhre war ein bisschen besser. Aber im Prinzip hattest du halt so ein flimmer Bild wie bei einem Fernseher. Und das war, glaube ich, das größte Problem vom Amiga. Deswegen ist er bei Spielen fürchterlich abgegangen, weil er auch so gut Sound hatte und alles. Aber zum Arbeiten war die Kiste eigentlich nicht so richtig geeignet, obwohl sie in vielerlei Hinsicht cooler war.
Also ich hatte einen Amiga ziemlich lange sogar, weil ich bin ja auch PC-Verweigerer, nicht nur Facebook, sondern PC-Verweigerer war ich ja ein bisschen immer noch eigentlich. Und gerade aktuell beschäftige ich mich ja auch schon seit jetzt schon ein paar Jahren, aber egal, mit Commodore-Floppies und Amiga-Floppies und überhaupt. Und ich glaube, der große Grund, warum der Amiga den Bachmutter gegangen ist, weil sie von Commodore gekauft wurden. Also weil der Amiga selbst war ja ziemlich cool, als er rauskam, aber da hat der Commodore nichts mehr damit gemacht. Also sie haben das ja irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Versauern lassen.
Versauern lassen und alles, was sie irgendwie erweitert haben, war immer nur fusch an allen Ecken und Enden. Wenn ich mir das jetzt immer so angucke, was ich da so rumbaste, da waren immer so Entscheidungen, nur um Geld zu sparen und was weiß ich nicht alles. Also es war ein Drama. Und als sie dann anfingen, das ein bisschen cooler zu machen, da war es schon zu spät, und dann waren sie auch ein Jahr später pleite.
Das Betriebssystem war eigentlich vom Ansatz her auch ganz cool, aber da haben sie sich halt irgendwie die Memory Management Unit gespart, weswegen...
Naja, das ging ja mit 68K Prozessor nicht. Da hatte der Atari ja auch nichts und der Macintosh hatte auch 68K, konnte das ja auch erstmal nicht.
SM124, nicht 1024.
Was ist das?
Das ist der Monitor von dem Atari, den...
War sehr berühmt. Mein Physiklehrer hatte... Hatte der Atari? Scheiße. Oder Beard? Nee, der hatte einen Atari vorher. Später hat er Mac gehabt, so war es. Aber vorher hat er mit einem Atari seine Schulunterlagen gemacht. Genau.
So, soll ich mal eine Tremille-Geschichte erzählen?
Ja, bitte.
Also wir waren sozusagen so ein bisschen die Atari Fanboys, einfach weil wir welche hatten. Und dann wohnte ich ja auch in Hannover und war ja auch so ein Cebit...
Dauergast.
Dauergast. Also Cebit war ja sozusagen für uns ein Standardprogramm. Also es war klar, dass wenn Cebit ist und in Abwesenheit von Internet gab es ja damals keine bessere Möglichkeit an Informationen und interessante Leute heranzukommen als auf der Cebit zu sein. Das kann man sich heutzutage nicht mehr vorstellen. Aber damals war das so. Da standen ja sogar noch teilweise sogar Programmierer am Stand. Muss man sich echt mal geben. Und zwar auch billig, weil man konnte immer so unterm Zaun durch und so. Das war alles ganz easy.
Weil man wusste wo?
Naja, aber ich wohnte ja...
Das ist wahrscheinlich wie mit dem Oktoberfest und den Leuten hier in München wohnen.
Heutzutage ist das natürlich alles generalstabsmäßig eingezäunt. Aber damals war das halt so das Messegelände. Da war so ein Zaun drumrum. Und dann haben wir uns da irgendwie gegraben unter einem Zaun. Und dann waren wir halt drin. Das war echt nicht das Thema. Naja, Schüler halt, keine Kohle, tralala. Vor allem, du wurdest ja auch nicht unbedingt immer reingelassen. Wegen Fachbesucher, tralala, Kinder und so. Wir waren auf jeden Fall immer da. Und was wir auch immer sehr erfolgreich gemacht haben so über die Jahre, war halt natürlich so dieses ganze Pressehacking. Das heißt, man versuchte halt möglichst immer an irgendwelche Presserausweise ranzukommen. Das war dann irgendwie auch, sagen wir mal, eine zumutbare Herausforderung. Man lernte ja so Leute kennen und lalala. Und irgendwie hatten wir es immer geschafft, Presserausweise zu haben, damit wir auf diese Partys kommen. Und damals war halt vor allem Commodore auch, aber vor allem Atari und interessanterweise übrigens auch Nokia. Damals immer diejenigen, die die Partys gemacht haben. Ich war mal auf einer Nokia Cebit-Party, die war wirklich legendär und wirklich, wirklich, wirklich lustig, weil sie sich tatsächlich geleistet haben, die Leningrad Cowboys dort auftreten zu lassen. Und das war wirklich das erste Mal in meinem Leben, wo ich so eine ganze Halle von Menschen so mit winkenden Handys, das ging wirklich damals nur auf einer Nokia-Fahrt, statt wirklich alle Mobiltelefone dabei hatten. Und statt Feuerzeuge zu zünden, haben sie einfach ihre Handys geschwenkt. Na ja, zurück zu Commodore, bzw. zu Atari. Atari hat halt auch immer so ein relativ modernes Pressespektapel gemacht, wo sie dann halt ihre neuen Sachen vorgestellt haben, lalala. Und damals wurde es halt noch echt zugearbeitet, als Journalist. Da gab es richtig schön Häppchen im Maritim und alles irgendwie kostenlos. Und tralala, große Party, großes Fressen. Und wir halt da irgendwie, ich und noch zwei Leute waren irgendwie so dabei und fanden das irgendwie alles ganz spannend. Und dann haben wir irgendwie diesen Tramiel einfach auf dieser Presseveranstaltung, wo er natürlich war, angesprochen, ob er nicht mal Bock hätte, ein paar Leute, die seinen Computer wirklich kaufen und benutzen, zu treffen. Und dann hat er echt Ja gesagt. Und ist dann, war das am gleichen Abend noch? Ich glaube, es war ein Tag später oder so, weil wir da unsere Dienstagstreffen sozusagen hatten in einer Kneipe. Ist er dann ernsthaft mit einem Techniker und Taxi angefangen gekommen und setzte sich dann irgendwie in die Kneipe, in so einen kleinen, verrauchten Raum.
In diesem Laden, wo sich der CCC immer getroffen hat?
Ja.
Also weil nicht der CCC war es in dem Sinne damals nicht, aber es war, sagen wir mal, das direkte Äquivalent zu dem. Wäre es nicht in Hannover gewesen, hätte es vielleicht CCC gehießen, aber es...
Nee, aber da ist ja immer dieser Laden...
Diese Hacker-Runde, ja, ja, das war die Runde halt. Damals.
Und auch der Laden ist doch der gleiche, wo die sich Jahre später immer noch getroffen haben, oder?
Ja, es gab ja mehrere. Ursprünglich war es das Bistro Casa, das ist so das, was so ein bisschen berühmter geworden ist. Dann waren wir im... Spektakel hieß der Laden. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es den noch gibt. Flügge Straße. Und der dicke Tramiel, weißt du, das ist so ein Wurzelzwerg gewesen. Der saß da irgendwie und fand das einfach so lustig. Der fand das einfach so cool, irgendwie so unter Leuten zu sein. Wir haben natürlich irgendwie alle möglichen...
Konnte er eigentlich Deutsch, weil...
Weil... Der ist ja Pole. Ich muss auch sagen, ich hab jetzt an der Wikipedia-Seite nach seinem Tod gelesen und hab jetzt erst festgestellt, der Typ war ein Auschwitz.
Ja, eben, hab ich auch gesehen.
Ist irgendwie dann verlegt worden, ausgerechnet noch in ein anderes Lager bei Hannover. Alem. Und ich saß halt mit ihm in Hannover irgendwie und hat Spaß. Also das war schon echt lustig. Der war einfach super. Der fand das so toll. Der hat sich die ganze Zeit weggeschmissen vor Lachen. Weil er das einfach... Der war sowieso schon total high irgendwie, weil er das einfach so cool fand. Und wir haben natürlich da seinen Techniker, den er mitgenommen hat, mit allen möglichen technischen Fragen gelöchert. Aber ich weiß nicht ganz genau, worum es überall ging. Das ist so lange her. Was war denn das? Atari ST? Wann ist der vorgestellt worden? Ja, das muss irgendwie so 1985 oder 1986 gewesen sein.
Und...
Das ist eigentlich schon die ganze Geschichte.
Spektakel gibt es noch in der Flügelschreise. Packsteinding.
Haben die auch immer noch so die ganzen Sachen an der Decke und so? Die haben immer so Tische und Lampen.
Das sieht man auf Google Street View nicht.
Nö, aber vielleicht wenn du mal Spektakel Hannover eingibst, dann hast du vielleicht entsprechende Bilder. Naja, so viel. Also, ich kann jetzt hier keinen großen Schwank erzählen, aber...
Der war schon vergleichsweise groß.
Ich hab ihn auf jeden Fall mal kennengelernt und er war wirklich ein lustiger Typ. Und insofern, danke Jack Tramiel, du hast mir den C64 gebracht. Auch den Atari ST, da bin ich nicht ganz so dankbar für.
Na, ohne diese...
Oh, die hat auch das passende T-Shirt an heute hier.
Ohne C64 wahrscheinlich würde ich auch nicht hier sitzen, weil so ging es ja los irgendwie. Also C64 und Dynamica halt.
Genau, bei mir auch.
Ja, der ist auch nicht so ein Quereinsteiger-Typ gewesen, sondern er ist ja wirklich... Er hat Commodore One Pound 50 gegründet.
Als Schreibmaschinenhersteller oder so, oder?
Commodore Typewriter und das dann langsam diese Richtung entwickelt und dann halt nach 20 Jahren zum Computer geführt. Und das war schon visionär. Lustigerweise, aus diesem, jetzt erinnere ich mich gerade wieder, aus diesem Treffen, aus diesem Treffen ging dann nämlich tatsächlich... Mal grübeln, genau, einer von uns, einer von uns ist nämlich glaube ich auf dieser Presseveranstaltung und dann tatsächlich mit ihm irgendwie ins Gespräch gekommen und der ist dann auch zu Atari gegangen. Also den haben sie gleich mitgenommen. Stimmt, jetzt wo ich mich...
Vielleicht direkt vor Ort eingestellt.
Und der war dann nämlich am Ende einer der allerletzten Employees von Atari überhaupt.
Liebste immer noch.
Na das halt ich...
Naja, aber das, das Atari, was die Computer gemacht hat, das, das, das originale Atari, das gab es dann irgendwann so nicht mehr. Naja, also interessante Lebensgeschichte. Der Typ hat auf jeden Fall was gerissen.
Nein, ich meine, er hat seinen Laden 54 gegründet und ich meine, da hatte er noch nichts mit Computern zu tun. Das heißt, das irgendwie so die Zukunft zu sehen oder gleich irgendwie aufs Neuste zu setzen, ist ja das, was viele Firmen immer nicht können. So gesehen hat er da schon was Großes geleistet, würde ich mal sagen. Also hat gesehen, wo die Richtung hingeht.
Ja, wer mal irgendwie auf demselben Sofa sitzen will, Spektakelflugestraße in Hannover. Seit hören uns ja auch Leute in Hannover zu. Wenn man da so reinkommt, gibt es da links einen kleinen abgeschlossenen Raum, eine kleine Treppe geht da, glaube ich, hoch. Das sieht man sofort.
Da haben sich die Hacker damals die Token Ring-Klinke in die Hand gegeben.
Ja, das war so ein bisschen eine von drei Geburtsstätten dieser hannuferschen Hacker-Szene. Ich hab ja noch ein Tool.
Du hast noch ein Tool?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich darüber reden darf.
Na ja, anfixen und dann nichts sagen.
Na ja, komm rück raus. Welche Kalender ist das diesmal?
Das ist kein Kalender, das ist das andere Problem. Ich hab zwar das Gefühl, ich hab das alles schon mal erzählt, aber da ich auch immer wieder gefragt werde, ich soll doch mal aufschreiben, was ich eigentlich meine und so. Egal, ich werd jetzt nicht die ganze Story erzählen. Ich will nur auf eine interessante Webseite hinweisen. Und zwar heißt die workflowy.com. Gibt's schon eine Weile, ist nichts wirklich brandneues. W-O-R-K, flowy.com. Und das ist ein ganz einfacher Outliner im Web.
Outliner.
Der wirklich nett gemacht ist. Und zwar, das ist wirklich so pure Outlining. So wie das eigentlich gedacht ist. Mit Folding und mit Hoisting und mit Indentation. Was heißt das? Also, Outlining heißt ja, ich mach eine hierarchische Struktur. Hoisting ist, du suchst dir irgendeinen Unterabschnitt raus und machst den quasi zu deinem temporären Route, sodass du dann nur darunter arbeitest. Und Folding ist halt generell dieses Ein- und Ausklappen, so wie man das eben kennt. Man im Finder, der Finder ist ja eigentlich, zusammen mit dem Dateisystem, auch so eine Art Outliner. Ist nicht wirklich genau das Gleiche, aber hat halt ähnliche Funktionen. Man kann halt folden, man kann auch hoisten, man kann ja sagen, jetzt machen wir ein Fenster auf, wo nur dieser Ordner und alles, was da drunter ist, angezeigt wird und dass da drüber, siehst du halt nicht, also ich gehe jetzt von diesem Apple II View aus, wo du eben... Naja, der Apple II View halt. Der gute alte Apple II View.
Oft kopierte, selten erreichte.
Als Liste heißt der bei mir.
Ja, den kenn ich auch.
Das ist mein Liebster. Ja, den nehm ich auch meistens. Ich arbeite eigentlich fast nur im Apple II.
Ich arbeite nur im Apple III. Ja, das ist mein...
Ach du bist so ein Spalten-Typ.
Ja, ich bin Spalter.
Ich bin mehr so ein Lister. Listiges Kerlchen, genau.
Ja, aber ich... Ich mag diesen Browser-Mode.
Ja, warum erwähne ich Workflow? Weil Workflow so schön pur ist. Ja, und das wäre so toll, wenn es sowas wie Workflow gäbe, in Verbindung mit Apps. Gibt's aber nicht. Applikationen.
In Verbindung mit Applikationen.
Da muss man gerade mal den Kloß aus dem Hals rauskriegen, sonst kann ich das nicht erklären. Naja, also ich finde ja, Outliner sind einfach zum Notieren von Dingen einfach toll. Weil wenn du über irgendwas nachdenkst, dann willst du eigentlich sowohl was schreiben, aber du willst eigentlich auch eine Struktur abbilden. Du willst Dinge, die zu irgendwas gehören, da reinpacken. So folder-mäßig. Du willst eine Gliederung haben, du willst eine Hierarchie haben, du willst vielleicht eine Reihenfolge auch abbilden. Und du willst vor allem Hierarchien und Reihenfolgen jederzeit leicht ändern können. Und genau das ist halt das, was Outliner leisten. Dass eben die Reihenfolge relevant ist und dass du eben mal eben sagen kannst, dieser ganze Ast hier, den schiebe ich jetzt mal an die Stelle und hier schiebe ich das eine Item hinter das andere Item, um einfach diese Liste zu ändern. Und dann kannst du eben schnell so eine Struktur, die du im Kopf hast, auch in eine reale, maschinenlesbare Struktur in deiner Software nieder schreiben. Sehr schön bei dem Workflow ist auch, dass sie so ein paar nette Sachen eingebaut haben, die man bei verschiedenen Outlinern mittlerweile findet, nämlich dass man da so auch so noch eine Notiz ran machen kann. Ja, also dass du sozusagen nicht nur dein Item hast, sondern eben auch noch zu dem Item einen Kommentar, ohne damit gleich eine Hierarchie-Stufe aufzumachen. Sehr schön, wenn du halt hier irgendwas notierst und dann die URL noch dazu etc.pp. Aber eben auch ganz klar die Hierarchie und das ist schon eine wichtige Sache. Das Problem ist hier jetzt wiederum, also der Vorteil ist auch noch, du kannst es leicht sharen, du kannst einen beliebigen Ast nehmen, also alles ist eine Outline, aber du kannst sie als mehrere separate Outlines ansehen und kannst sie dann auch sharen. Kannst sagen, ich mach jetzt hier irgendwie eine neue Notiz auf, quasi in deinem Top-Level schreibst du was rein und kannst das dann sharen. Schenkst dir irgendjemand einen Link und dann kann er eben diesen Baum mit bearbeiten und dann können mehrere Leute da auch gleichzeitig dran arbeiten. Das funktioniert schon mal ganz gut. Aber es gibt halt keine App dafür. Es gibt keine App für iOS, es gibt keine App für Mac und das ist das Problem. Und auf der anderen Seite hast du eben Sachen wie Omni-Outliner, die ganz toll sind, um Outlines eben auf Mac zu machen und mittlerweile auch auf iOS.
Aber Omni-Outliner ist ein ziemliches Schwergewicht geworden inzwischen.
Ja, Omni-Outliner 3 ist eigentlich ein Fehler gewesen.
Die Omni-Group ist auch so ein bisschen hart abgekommen.
Ja, zu dick. Also Omni-Outliner 3 benutze ich eigentlich nur noch, weil ich da irgendwann mal in die Upgrade-Falle reingetappt bin. Omni-Outliner 2, das war die reine Lehre. Das war wirklich super, aber dann sind sie so in diesem Rich-Text-Teufel verfallen. Wo dann irgendwie, du pastest was rein und dann ist es irgendwie rot und grün und unterstrichen und groß und klein und font und denkst dir dann so, ich will einfach nur eine Scheiß-Information notieren. Und dann hast du da so viel Dreck, mit dem ich mich einfach gar nicht befassen will. Also das ist der große Fail. Also Omni-Outliner haben sie versucht, in irgendwas zu bewegen. Es mag Leute geben, die das ganz toll finden, aber für mich ist es schon wieder too much. So jetzt vielleicht noch ein letzter Satz dazu, was ich mir eigentlich vorstelle, was wirklich das coole Notiztool wäre und wo ich echt eine Development Opportunity sehe. Und ich hab mich auch neulich hier nochmal mit Dom und Martin von Coding Monkeys über das Thema unterhalten, weil ja auch immer so ein bisschen meine Wunschkandidaten waren, das Problem mal zu lösen, weil sie ja ein ähnliches Problem schon sehr gut gelöst haben. Nämlich mit SubEtherEdit dieses Kollaborative editieren. Es gibt verschiedene Sachen. Du willst natürlich sowas sharen, aber du willst eben auch so einen Realtime-Editor haben. Und du willst aber auch einen Offline-Sync haben. Das sind also verschiedene Dinge, die man irgendwie zusammenbringen muss. Und das ist natürlich nicht einfach. Aber angenommen, man geht das jetzt mal an und man verwendet dann eine ordentliche einfache Struktur, die man halt auf irgendeinem Server speichern kann, sodass du sagen kannst, hier neues Dokument, zack, bumm, das pack ich auf den Server. Dann kannst du es mit anderen Leuten sharen, etc., pp. Und dann greifst du darauf zu, entweder übers Web oder eben über eine App. Mir persönlich würden Apps schon reichen, aber es ist auch jetzt kein Fehler, wenn es das auch noch im Web gibt. Und dann kannst du eben in Echtzeit daran arbeiten. Und zwar so sehr in Echtzeit, dass man wirklich parallel gleichzeitig, wie man das jetzt mittlerweile auch von Etherpad gewohnt ist oder teilen auch Google Docs oder eben Sub-Ether-Eden, dass man einfach an diesem Dokument gleichzeitig arbeiten kann. Die Herausforderung dabei ist, dass du mit in Transformationen denken musst. Du musst quasi, ist nicht so wie dein Programm ist Herrscher über das Dokument und du fügst dann am Ende was ein. So geht es nicht. Sondern du musst das komplex angehen und musst sagen, hier ist eine Transformation. Ich möchte gerne, dass dieser Zustand in diesen Zustand überführt wird. Und das musst du dann eben auch gekapselt übermitteln und dann eben kombinieren mit anderen Transaktionen, die in dem Moment gestartet worden sind. Also Transformation als Transaktion ansehen, etc. Also musst du transaktionsorientiert wie eine Datenbank, musst du eigentlich auch diese kleine Minidatenstruktur angehen. Und das geht. Das ist nicht unmöglich. Das ist jetzt nicht total einfach, aber es ist zumindest interessant. Und damit hätte man wirklich einen Notizzettel, der Deluxe ist. So was stell ich mir vor. Aber hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Notizzettel Deluxe.
Ja, durierte Gedanken in Echtzeit, aber auch offline erfassen können und nachträglich sinken. Das ist die Herausforderung und das mit Ups. Und das sowohl auf Mac als auch auf IOS. Was mich betrifft, ist das keine Voraussetzung meinetwegen. Ich meine, am Ende, wenn man da seine Algorithmen umgesetzt hat, dann lassen die sich auf jedem OS sicherlich auf irgendeine Art und Weise umsetzen. Ja, ich weiß. Ich bin auch nicht davon ausgegangen, dass wir irgendwas ernst meinen hier. Aber schaut euch mal workflow.com an, das kann man kostenlos benutzen. Und da sieht man mal, was ein eleganter Outliner ist, der sich wirklich auf das Wesentliche reduziert.
Her damit.
Software-Empfehlung für Nerds. Ist auch nur so halb ernst gemeint. Aber ich habe jahrelang immer die eine Software benutzt und dachte, ja, das ist jetzt schon gut genug und da brauchen wir jetzt nicht noch mal was Neues. Dann gab es noch ringsum darum sozusagen alternative Applikationen. Ich dachte, die können jetzt auch nichts besser. Die Rede ist natürlich von Shales fürs Terminal. Ich habe jahrelang die Bash benutzt. Und war damit ja eigentlich auch total zufrieden. Jetzt hab ich es doch nochmal. Ich hab schon mal ZSR benutzt, aber wenn die so plain daherkommt, wie auf OS X so unkonfiguriert und alles, dann ist sie halt so ein bisschen, so erstmal ein bisschen sperriger, finde ich. Zumindest verhält sie sich nicht so smooth wie die Bash in Default-Zustand. Aber jetzt hab ich sie mir ja doch mal ein bisschen konfiguriert und jetzt, ja, ich hier auch eine Mate. Und jetzt will ich ja doch nicht mehr wieder zurück. Naja, also schon alleine, dass du anfangen kannst, einen Command zu tippen und dann machst du Pfeil hoch und dann completet er. Also dann geht der nicht. Genau, also das ist schon, das allein ist schon so ein Killer-Feature, was irgendwie Produktivität nach vorne bringt. Und dieses Completen, wo du dann ein Menü hast quasi, also du drückst jetzt zum Beispiel ein Verzeichnis.
Also das er dir alle möglichen Complets schon anzeigt.
Und du kannst dann halt mit entweder weiter tippen, weiter einschränken oder mit den Maustasten, mit den Cursor-Tasten halt an das richtige Dimension bringen und weiter komplizieren.
Aber es ist alles nicht in ZSH-Default auf dem Mac, ne?
Es ist nicht default an, aber es gehört, ja. Genau, das sind halt so diese ganzen Sachen.
Na dann, mach doch mal als Hausaufgabe zur nächsten Sendung eine richtig schick, geile ZSH-Einstellungsdatei und dann reden wir noch mal.
Es gibt halt tatsächlich auch ein Projekt, womit ich zum Beispiel angefangen habe, das heißt Oh My ZSH, ist auf GitHub. Das heißt tatsächlich so. Nee, das ist eigentlich nur so ein Skript mehr oder weniger, was dir erstmal so ein stapelthemen installiert und ein bisschen Default-Config und das habe ich als erstes mal ausprobiert, weil ein Kollege das halt mir empfohlen hatte. Das macht viel mehr als ich überhaupt jemals braucht habe. Es war ein guter Startpunkt, um mal zu sehen, was geht. Also ich pack mal den Link einfach zu dem GitHub repo rein. Dann kann man sich das mal angucken. Und im Wesentlichen, da ist auch beschrieben, was das alles tut. Und man kann dann auch selber eben noch eingreifen. Und ich habe dann auch ganz viel wieder rausgeschmissen von dem Kram. Aber mit dem Ding war es halt erstmal in so einem Zustand, dass die ganzen Features an waren und ich überhaupt erst mal die Sonne gesehen habe. Vorher, wenn du jetzt halt die ZSH im normalen OSX auspackst, dann ist da nichts mit Sonne, sondern dann ist so Nachtschattengewächs. Die ja auch ihre Vorzüge haben. Also meine Empfehlung an die Herren da draußen, die und Damen natürlich auch, die mit vielen Terminen unterwegs sind und bisher immer nur die Bish benutzt haben oder vielleicht sogar die, was gibt es noch? Sich nochmal die ZSH anzugucken, weil die macht echt Spaß. In einem deiner Podcast hat ja mal Hans, nee Quatsch, Hans hat irgendwann mal getwittert, glaube ich, dass er bis bis zum heutigen Tag quasi noch TCSH oder sowas benutzt hat. Und dann sozusagen jetzt im Jahre 2011 oder 12 auf die Bash gewechselt ist und dann schon, was geht denn da plötzlich ab an Features, an der es gleich noch auf die ZSH gewechselt wäre?
Also ich habe damals auch ZSH benutzt und zwar unter DOS. Und ich grübel jetzt gerade, das gibt es glaube ich auch heute noch, ja ja unter DOS und zwar gibt es einen, wie heißt denn das nochmal, verdammt.
Passt das denn überhaupt rein?
Ist die so alt schon?
In die 640 Kilobyte von DOS?
Die ZSH, ja guck mal nach, aber die ZSH gibt es definitiv schon seit den 80ern. Irgendwann. Und es gab, wie heißt denn das, gibt es ein komplettes Kit, so vollständiges Unix Command Line Set für DOS und meinetwegen auch für Windows. Das gibt es schon seit Ewigkeiten und ich glaube, das gibt es auch immer noch.
1990 wurde sie gewählt.
Aber du redest nicht von Cyquin.
Nein, ich rede nicht von Cyquin, sondern ich rede von was anderem. Wie hieß denn das nochmal, verdammt, das war relativ bekannt. Und ich vermute auch mal, dass es das in irgendeiner Form immer noch gab, weil ich war, 90 gab es die ZSH, 90.
Stimmt, da gab es auch noch. Irgendwas gab es da noch. Ich erinnere mich auch, Vage.
Komm nicht mehr so richtig drauf. Und meines Wissens kam das dann auch, wenn nicht in der ersten Version, dann später mit einer ZSH und dann war das meine Default Shell. Und damit konnte man halt unter, konnte man es unter DOS äh, ertragen.
MinGW? Wird da gefragt?
Nee.
Ist jetzt echt zu lange her.
War aber ein tolles Set, so. Und da haben sie wirklich auch alles untergebracht, was man so brauchte. Und vor allem unter DOS konnte es ja mit der Kommando-Zeile einfach überhaupt nichts bewirken. Und ich mein, es war nicht alles jetzt total mega vollständig und so.
Also wenn mal Jürgen oder Atari kam, dann war DOS auf jeden Fall unter aller Sau.
Oder?
Wenn man von was kam?
Amiga oder Atari?
Na ich kam nicht vom Atari. Atari war ja auch nur DOS. Ja, das war wirklich DOS. Also die haben sogar dieselben System-Calls gehabt. Es war halt nur anders, weil es 68K war. Aber ansonsten war es dieselbe Abstaktion.
Gab es da eine Kommando-Zeile eigentlich? Die hab ich glaube ich nie gesehen.
Auf Namiga gab es auch.
Ja, ich weiß.
CLI, Command Line Interface.
Wie hieß denn nur dieses verdammte Scheiße? Das ärgert mich jetzt, dass ich da nicht drauf komme.
Kannst ja mal googeln nach Sequin Alternative oder sowas.
Das war lange vor Sequin. Sequin gab es da glaube ich noch nicht.
Was sagt denn die Themenkarte?
Na hier, warte mal, gerade im Chat hat ja einer nochmal dieses Mosh, diese Mobile Shell erwähnt. Die ist ja auch die Woche an mir vorbei gescaled, wollte ich gerade sagen, gescrollt. Aber ich hab noch gar nicht genau geguckt, was es eigentlich tut. Mosh ist a replacement for SSH. Also es ist von MIT offensichtlich. Du kannst ja mal auf mosh.mit.edu klicken und dann herausfinden. Hab ich mir noch nicht angeguckt.
Wenn das gut ist, dann kommt es auch nochmal wieder. Ich mach mir da keine Sorgen.
Ah, jetzt weiß ich es wieder. MKS Toolkit. Das MKS Toolkit. Gucken, ob es die immer noch gibt. MKS Software gibt es immer noch. Linux-like environment, mittlerweile heißt es Linux-like environment, vor Windows. Ha, krass, die gibt es immer noch. Glaublich.
Benutzst du eigentlich auch T-Mux oder Screen?
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, wenn ich auf dem Server irgendwie zu tun habe und da rumeditiere und entwickle, dann eher T-Mux als Screen. Screen ist irgendwie, fühlt sich so ein bisschen, weiß nicht, wäre ich nicht warm mit. Und T-Mux verhält sich so ein bisschen. Ich hab's probiert. Aber es war immer so ein bisschen im Weg. Und T-Mux ist deutlich weniger im Weg.
Verstehe.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich täglich im T-Mux unterwegs bin.
Tja, mittlerweile ist dieses MKS Toolkit, glaube ich, beyond, das ist irgendwie, wenn irgendwas anderes hinein geht.
Die Windows-Fanboys würden jetzt ja sagen, es gibt ja jetzt auch die Microsoft PowerShell, da braucht man unter Windows gar keine.
Ich rede ja immer nur von früher. Ja, mittlerweile ist das keine Ahnung, was das hier mittlerweile für ein Produkt geworden ist.
Aber da hattest du schon die ZSH, das war ja der eigentliche Sprung.
Genau, da hatte ich ZSH und ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich auch viel Spaß hatte mit ZSH. Ich weiß bloß nicht mehr so richtig, warum ich eigentlich nie so richtig weiter marschiert bin. Kann sein, dass die Unix-Systeme, die ich danach hatte, dann irgendwie erstmal keine hatten oder keine Ahnung.
Ja, das ist ja...
Ich war wahrscheinlich viel zu lange auf dem Mac.
Was macht unser Hörometer eigentlich?
Ist dein Screen abgekackt?
Hättest du mal Mosch benutzt.
Ja, ist irgendwie abgekackt.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Ja, ne, aber auf jeden Fall war auch für mich so nach Jahren der Besch-Benutzung eine schöne Erfahrung, doch nochmal auf eine andere Shell zu wechseln.
Jetzt sollte ich das mal ausprobieren.
Ja, aber wie gesagt so, wenn du eben die Nacki auf OS X benutzt, dann macht die erstmal nicht so viel Spaß. Also man muss schon erstmal ein paar Options antongeln. Aber ich kann in meinen Githab-Rebo, ich hab ja da irgendwo glaube ich ein Repository mit so meinen Konfig-Files drin, da kann ich auch gerne meine ZSH-Konfig nochmal reindödeln. Sah ich nochmal Bescheid auf Twitter vielleicht.
Aber hier gibt es ja noch so eine Apple is Evil-Meldung. Da hab ich nur so am Rand überhaupt Aufmerksamkeit schenken können. Das hab ich nur so in meinem Urlaub so ein bisschen... Die da gewesen wäre? Hier gab es auch so auf Heise eine Meldung, dass Apple und Google Smartphones für Strafverfolger entsperren. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Naja, wundert mich jetzt nicht.
Nö, mich auch nicht.
Aber was heißt entsperren?
Na, Dollar-Strafverfolgungsbehörde hat halt irgendwie ein Telefon von irgendwem einkassiert. Und dann rufen sie halt bei Apple an, oder besser gesagt schicken, da so ein Schreiben, was da auch schon irgendwie erwähnt war, dass es da welche Templates hier gibt oder sowas. Füllen aus irgendwie hier folgendes Telefon mit folgender Nummer und dann kriegen sie von Apple irgendwie den Code zurück, mit dem man es entsperren kann.
Oder so.
Oder kriegen eine Anleitung, wie man es halt entsperren kann.
All diese Sperre, die ist auch immer noch total umgehbar auf dem iPhone, ist doch eh alles neu.
Ja, dann Jailbreak ist ja sowieso, oder? Da machst du irgendwie dieses Red Snow, Red Rain, wie heißt das ganze Zeug, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, ich hab den übrigens mit verloren.
Übrigens ein Phone in DFU-Modus, kannst da neue Images einspielen und danach ist es ja mehr oder weniger offen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was der aktuelle Jailbreak-Stun so ist. Hab mich ja irgendwie, seitdem ich keinen Bock mehr drauf hatte, nie wieder mit beschäftigt.
Geht mir ähnlich.
Aber da gibt es auch noch News, wenn wir schon mal sind und Tim noch ein bisschen Management machen muss hier. Auch am Sonntag, so wie Nokia, ist irgendwie anscheinend bei den Amis beliebt, Termine auf Oster-Sontag zu legen. Kann man bei AT&T jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob es noch Leute betrifft hier, weil wahrscheinlich alle sich schon jetzt hier in Deutschland oder Europa ein iPhone besorgt hatten. Kann man bei AT&T jetzt auch sein iPhone entsperren lassen, wenn es irgendwie vertragsfrei ist oder der Vertrag irgendwie zumindestens einen positiven Kontostand hat oder irgendwie so. Und kann sich das anlocken lassen. Es betrifft halt Leute, die sich noch irgendwie, aus welchen Gründen auch immer, aus Amerika ein Phone haben mitbringen lassen und das irgendwie AT&T gelockt war.
Interessant fand ich die Meldung, dass irgendwie Militärangehörige, die im Ausland stationiert sind, sich das auch noch während ihrer Vertragslaufzeit anlocken lassen kann.
Das ist halt für die Truppe.
Das geht natürlich vor. It's for the country, my son.
Aber sie haben nicht offiziell zugegeben, dass sie das machen, sondern das scheinen sie so halb offiziell unter der Hand zu machen.
Ja, ansonsten ist ja wirklich nicht mehr da mal nix passiert.
Diablo 3 Beta.
Hat sich eigentlich jemand von euch jetzt ein neues iPad gekauft?
Kollege von mir, aber ich hab noch nicht mal raufgeguckt.
Ja.
Du hast noch nicht mal drauf, ihr habt noch keins gesehen.
Doch.
Doch, klar.
In der Firma sind lauter iPads. Vor zwei Wochen. Aber ich hab, ich hab nur keinen... Use case. Mich hat's noch nicht interessiert, tatsächlich.
Du hast ja ein iPad, oder?
Ich hab ja ein iPad zu Hause, erst mal, ja. Weil ich hatte jetzt eh nicht vor mir noch eins jetzt demnächst zu besorgen, also.
Verständlich, dass man jetzt keinen Immediate-Upgrade hat. Na, ich häng ja eigentlich noch auf meinem iPad 1 fest, aber ich benutze einfach mein iPad so selten. Ja, weil ich einen MacBook Air hab, aber ich fühl mich ja irgendwie auch immer nach, ich fühl mich ja mittlerweile richtig schlecht irgendwie, was... wie ich von Apple behandelt werde.
Immer noch kein SIM-Card-Slot im Air.
Ich meine, mittlerweile wird's albern.
Ja.
Also es ist... Ich kann nicht verstehen, dass ein Gerät... Ich meine, wenn du dir ein neues iPad kaufst, mit mittlerweile ja sogar 4G in Anführungsstrichen.
Sehr Anführungsstriche. Dafür haben sie in diversen Ländern aufs Maul gekriegt.
Sagen wir mal so. Ein iPad mit amtlichem 3G-Support. Wie lang ist drin? 64 GB SSD.
Ist drittner Flash-Speicher. SSD würde ich das nicht nennen. Dazu ist es nämlich zu langsam.
Ist es langsam?
Solid State heißt es. Hat mit Speed nichts zu tun.
Ja, ja, es hat mit Speed nichts zu tun. Aber bei einer SSD, die kauft man, weil sie schnell ist. Und der Flash-Speicher, der im iPad drin ist, der ist halt da drin, weil er da drin ist. Also das ist jetzt...
Ja gut, aber kennst du den, den, den, die, die Speck? Ich meine, der Zugriff wird ja jetzt nicht langsam sein.
Nein, ist nicht direkt langsam. Aber es ist halt nicht wie eine SSD, sondern eher wie ein USB-Stick. Wie so ein Wald- und Wiesen-USB-Stick. Also es ist schon okay.
Hat das eigentlich mal irgendwer gemessen? Nee, ne?
Bist du sicher? Ich meine, ja.
Ich kenne keine Zahlen.
Ich hab keine Zahlen.
Ja. Man verdreht ja auch nicht so viel Speicher. Aber na gut, wie auch immer. Es ist da drin. Was kostet das Gerät? 3G, 64.
820 oder 830 in der Config, glaube ich.
Viel auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal, was der Tagespreis ist auf Apple.
Für so ein bisschen Sofasurfen.
Schau es mal nach aktuellen Angeboten.
Eine Apple-Aktie. Nee, noch ein bisschen drauflegen. 1,3 Apple-Aktien.
Schwarz, 64GB, kostet 800 Euro. 800 Euro brutto. Was kostet das MacBook Air? Kostet ab 1200 Euro mehr und hat 128 GB SSD, hat eine Tastatur, hat einen schlechteren Bildschirm. Was hat es noch? Es hat die Hälfte der Akkuzeit.
Eigentlich voll schlechter.
Eigentlich schwerer.
Es hat doppelt so viel Betriebssystem.
Dafür hat es USB, es hat Audioeingang.
Und die Hülle ist schon dabei. Der Deckel nämlich zum Zumachen.
Das stimmt. Und es hat natürlich einen Prozessor, der viel viel viel viel schneller ist als der im iPad. Und die Grafik, weiß ich nicht, wird wahrscheinlich sich ähnlich verhalten. Also das ist schon ein bisschen toller, aber es hat halt vor allem diesen ganzen 3G-Scheiß nicht. Und nicht so ein gutes Display. Was spricht dagegen, dieses R mit diesem selben 3G-Support, den das iPad hat, zu bauen? Nichts.
Da würde niemand mehr die teuren iPads kaufen.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Ich meine, wir sind doch alle Überzeugungstäter. Ich komme nicht klar mit dem iPad.
Ich bin Wiederholungstäter sogar.
Für was?
Man kann natürlich jetzt die Hoffnung haben, dass sich was ändert. Zum Beispiel soll ja Tim Cook irgendwie die Keynote von der All Things Die sprechen, habe ich heute gelesen.
Wirklich?
Habe ich irgendwo gelesen, ja.
Okay.
Habe ich nur so überflogen. Also das hieße, dass sich die Firma jetzt irgendwie anders geriert.
Na das tut es ja mittlerweile.
Vielleicht ist da auch 3G fürs R drin.
Nein.
Das glaube ich. Also so werden sie sich nicht gerieren, dass sie jetzt anfangen, Produkt-Announcements auf so komischen Talk-Bühnen zu machen.
Nein, nicht, dass sie dort ein Produkt...
Ach du meinst, wenn sie schon Keynotes auf solchen Konferenzen machen, dann können sie auch 3G in ein MacBook Air einbauen?
Ja, das meine ich. Ja, natürlich.
Ich verstehe es nicht. Also ich frage mich, ich meine, was denken die sich?
Was erlaube Koch?
Man könnte immer noch meinen, du meinst den da aus Hessen, diesen...
Ja, der Koch muss einfach mal Entscheidungen fällen.
Du bist auch eine Schnarchennase. Ja, der kann nicht erzählen. Da schlafe ich immer ein.
Ja, aber vielleicht kann er richtig entscheiden.
Ja, ich hoffe. Wie lange dauert es denn noch, bis wir den Schatten von Tim sehen? Also bis sozusagen seine Hebel, Schaltungen und Waltung dann auch beim User ankommen sozusagen. Noch ist ja wahrscheinlich alles noch Steve geprägt.
Er hat ja Gazillionen von neuen Produkten angekündigt, mehr oder weniger bei der letzten iPad.
Ja, aber es ist hier schon Mitte April, junger Mann. Wann will er die rausholen? Alle vor Weihnachten oder was?
Glaubst du, dass Apple was Neues bringt dieses Jahr?
Mountain Lion, iOS 6, das neue iPhone.
Nee, irgendwas, was noch nicht da war.
So, kein Update meinst du, sondern was Neues?
Was Neues, ein Gerät, was ist in der Form?
Ein neues Gerät, so wie das iPad damals ein neues Gerät war.
Ja.
Nö, dieses Jahr nicht.
Glaub ich auch nicht.
Höchstens, den Fernseher.
Ich bin mir da immer noch nicht so sicher, wie das aussehen sollte.
Das wäre ein neues Gerät, und den hab ich noch nicht komplett abgeschrieben.
Und das MacBook Pro Air, würde das zählen?
Das zählt eher nicht.
Kommt drauf an, wie es so positioniert ist.
Daran, also das wäre so für mich gerade so das Höchste der neuen Produktgefühle, was ich mir vorstelle.
Also ich würd sagen, so ein 15 Zoll Air werden wir auf jeden Fall sehen. Ich bin mir bloß noch nicht so sicher, ob das dann auch bedeutet, dass das Pro in der Form so nicht mehr existiert. Aber ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht, wenn das 13er komplett unter den Tisch fällt, das 15er auch aerifiziert wird.
Na aerifiziert hieß er ja erstmal nur optisches Laufwerk raus. Und das ist ja nur echt überfördlich.
Und Festplatte raus. Und vielleicht High Resolution Double DPI Display rein.
Und Firewire 800 raus.
High Resolution DPI irgendwas, das muss überhaupt erstmal jemand produzieren, bevor...
Also vor allem in der Größe.
Was würden wir vorher hören, meinen Sie, wenn Firmen plötzlich so eine Display bauen?
Na ja, ich hab jetzt gelesen, da haben sie irgendwie einen großen Monitor vorgestellt, der hat jetzt so viel Pixel wie das neue iPad, nur halt irgendwie in 30 Zoll oder so.
4096 x 2000 irgendwas.
Das wurde jetzt als großer Durchbruch gefeiert. Ich meine, jetzt hat das iPad, wie viel hat es? 11 Zoll. Wenn jetzt 11 Zoll auf 15 Zoll und dann immer noch Retina oder HiDPI haben willst. Hey, das kann ich mir nur so schwer vorstellen.
Sie müssen ja nicht komplett verdoppeln, weil es ja hier mit der Größe noch einigermaßen dynamisch ist. Also sie müssen sich ja nicht an Zahlen halten.
Na gut, 50% mehr Pixel. Also auf die Länge gerechnet. Das ist schon was, das musste erst mal stemmen. 50% mehr auf die Länge, also ungefähr die Hälfte mehr, wäre jetzt so.
Also meinst du so 2500 an Breite.
Na wie viel DPI hat denn euer?
Ich glaube so an 116 oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Das ist jetzt was, was ich jetzt nur gar nicht so schnell ausrechnen könnte.
160.
Da müsste man auf der Webseite gucken, auf die Maße und dann... Da sind doch die Teche Specs.
Die Teche Specs?
Ja, apple.com, zack.
Was sagt denn der Monitor?
Das war auf jeden Fall nicht viel.
Der sagt 1680 auf die lange Seite.
So, Teche Specs und 15 Inch. Und gibt es hier schon DP?
Das wird ja wieder live gerechnet in der Sendung.
Also wir haben beim Bildschirm... Da sind gar keine Maße, du. Na, da steht nur die Diagonale, aber nicht Höhe und Breite.
Lass mich raten, bei der Diagonale steht 15 Zoll.
Ich hätte das mit der höheren Auflösung damals mir zusammengeklickt.
1600 Mal hast du nicht gesehen.
Wie auch immer. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch nicht wirklich ein neues Gerät. Was noch kommen könnte, glaube ich aber auch nicht so richtig dran, ist Mac Pro irgendwie, Updates, die anders aussehen. Aber es ist am Ende auch nur eine Ablösung. Es ist ja nichts wirklich Neues. Also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie mit einem kompakteren Mac Pro Gehäuse kommen, wenn überhaupt noch.
Ja, also dass man den 19 Zoll schrauben könnte, wäre geil.
Ja, nee, glaube ich nicht. Interessiert die überhaupt gar nicht.
Doch, das ist, ich meine, das ist das, was du brauchst. Nein, das ist einfach für Pro-Anwender. Die Leute, die sich so ein Gerät kaufen, die wollen das auch gut wegstacken können. Und wenn sie den Formfaktor ein bisschen kleiner machen, wenn sie irgendwas wegreduzieren, wenn sie sagen, ihr braucht nicht mehr so viel Slots und wir brauchen nicht mehr so viel Lüfter oder wir brauchen nicht mehr so viel CD-Laufwerke oder irgendwas, dass sie es irgendwie kompakter machen, so dass es eben durch irgendeinen Kniff Griffe abnehmen, irgendwas und dann Schienen ran schrauben und dann kannst du es auch in 19 Zoll einbauen.
Voll Apple-untypisch.
Dann hast du hinten Thunderbolt raus und klemmst noch eine Bay dazu.
Ihre X-Surf nicht eingestellt.
Aber X-Surf ist ein ganz anderes Produkt. Ein X-Surf ist ein lärmendes, riesiges Monster.
Dacht du, du willst es auch noch leise haben?
Der Mac Pro ist leise. Warum würde der jetzt auf einmal wieder laut werden, nachdem sie ihn jahrelang leise gekämpft haben?
Das heißt, du willst also ein...
Ein leises Gerät, was man aber auch in eine 19 Zoll... Das kann ja auch so ein Tisch-Rack sein, irgendwas, dass du ihn einfach besser dahin stellen kannst.
Da gucken die nach, da wissen sie alles klar, es brauchen nicht mehr als 10.000 Leute auf dieser Welt.
Also...
Ich wär mir da nicht so unsicher. Könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das kommt.
Als kleines Update zu den PPIs, ja. Das MacBook Pro 15 Zoll mit hoher Auflösung hat 128. PPI, das 17 Zoll hat 132. Und die iOS-Geräte haben tatsächlich durch die Bank weg das Beste. Und MacBook Air 11 Inch hat 135. Also MacBook Air 11 Zoll ist das Notebook mit den höchsten PPI.
135, was hat das, ein iPad 2?
Das iPad 3 hat 264.
264, also das doppelte.
Und das iPhone hat 326.
In anderen Worten, würde man auf dem 11 Zoll verdoppeln, hätte man eine Retina. Wäre es tatsächlich mehr oder weniger genauso wie beim iPad.
Das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt vorstellen, dass sie von unten sich rantasten und die Geräte von kleiner nach größer verretinifizieren. Erst das 11 Zoll, vielleicht noch das 13 dazu, später 15, 17, da wird es dann schon schwierig.
Na ja, es sind ja nicht so viele Geräte wie iPad.
Man wird ja glatt wetten, also so ein 27 Zoll iMac, bis der retinifiziert ist, dauert es noch zwei Jahre.
Mindestens.
Weil so ein Display musst du erstmal herstellen.
Ja, aber den Preis, den die Apple nimmt, da kann man das auch mal machen.
Das macht bei den Laptops ja auch mehr Sinn, weil du da näher dran sitzt. Bei so einem 27 Zoll iMac hast du in der Regel einen größeren Abstand. Und die Laptops, die hast du halt auf dem Lab. Hence the name. Da sitzt du relativ nah am Bildschirm. Und da macht eine hohe Auflösung was aus.
Es sei denn, du spielst und das Teil wird wieder scheiß heiß.
Ich guck mir lieber jetzt nochmal kurz das an, wie das jetzt hier alles aussieht, weil nachdem es dann Retina ist, findet man es dann nachher total scheiße.
Genieß es nochmal, solange du es noch nicht scheiße findest.
Na gut, wo waren wir? Wir waren bei neuen Geräten. Also Fernseher?
Fernseher ist im Bereich des Möglichen.
Nee, ich glaub da mittlerweile nicht mehr dran. Also, dass sie wirklich so ein Fernsehergerät ausliefern, scheitert einfach noch an der Situation, dass sie dafür noch nicht genug Content haben. Ich glaub, sie müssen beim Content erst den Durchbruch erzielen. Und ihre Fernsehstrategie ist einfach diese kleine schwarze Box, die ich jetzt auch schon mal hingestellt habe. In der Zeitung, in der man besserer Zeiten.
Interessiert mich auch nicht zentral, muss ich sagen.
Bist du nicht so interessiert an Fernsehen? Und Bayern gegen BVB? Auch nicht, interessiert dich auch nicht.
Nee, finde ich schön, dass BVB jetzt ein Tor geschossen hat, aber...
Gewonnen haben sie.
Du, das letzte Mal, dass ich Bayern-Fan war, das ist, glaube ich, so um die 30 Jahre her. Also, insofern...
Also, ich hätte ja nichts dagegen, wenn es... Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Gut, also keine neuen Geräte. Und Mountain Lion interessiert auch überhaupt keine Sau. Hab ich festgestellt. Also, sonst, wenn Apple ein neues OS irgendwie in der Pipeline hatte, da, also, bist du ja noch früher, Dennis, da ist das Erste, was da irgendwo gelegt ist gleich.
Gleich Bilder aufgeknallt und alles gemacht und getan und heute.
Und das Mountain Lion, ehrlich gesagt, ich will mir das gar nicht installieren, aber den ganzen GUI-Gedödel und Firle-Fanz, der jetzt da zugekommen ist, rauche ich alles nicht. Ich geh weg.
Hab ich das letzte wieder gesehen, also, kenn ich ja so Leute, die das benutzen, ne? Und, ähm, wenn man hier normalerweise was kopiert im Finder, dann kommt auch so ein kleines Fenster mit so einem Progress Bar. Und das ist jetzt, glaube ich, immer noch da, aber zusätzlich ist halt im Finder an der Stelle sozusagen, wo das Ziel ist von dem, was du kopierst, ist da auch ein Progress Bar an der Stelle, wo sozusagen dein Feilname ist, also...
So wie die Apps, die installiert werden.
So ein bisschen, so könnte man das sehen, ja, genau.
Das sind natürlich große Änderungen. Ja, da hab ich nix gegen.
Aber irgendwie hab ich gerade so diese Bloatangst, oder irgendwie, dass da wieder so ein komischer Kokolores dazukommt, der dann alles wieder langsamer und komischer und dann irgendwie wieder so effektiv...
Der ist schon da, der Kokolores, und das ist der, der dafür sorgt, dass du möglichst alles in der iCloud speichern sollst.
Ja, die große Hockerhauung hat nicht stattgefunden bis jetzt. Die große Hockerhauung, vom Hockerhauung. Hatten nicht stattgefunden.
Das ist eher so die Tumbleweed-Grillenzuppen-Stimmung.
Also, ich weiß ich nicht, ich hab noch so die leise Hoffnung, dass sie halt vielleicht noch irgendeinen Feature dann tatsächlich, wenn sie so weit sind, dann irgendwie noch mal sein.
Das Pfeilsystem.
Aber keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch nicht, was da im Sommer passieren soll. Also ich kann mir halt vorstellen, dass Mountain Lion und dann irgendeine Art von iOS-Update zusammen irgendwie den großen iCloud-Zirkus dann mal ins große Reiten bringen sollen. Aber ansonsten, ich meine, ich finde iCloud auch so uninteressant irgendwie.
Wir wachsen irgendwie so ein bisschen raus aus dem Apple-Universum, wir sind so altschulig hier.
Ja, aber dieses iCloud, das wird noch, große Schmerzen wird das bedeuten, ich bin mir sicher.
Das Schlimme ist mit diesem iCloud und so, oder ob, also wo wir halt Angst vor haben, dass halt alles irgendwie Apple ist, weil wenn ich irgendwelche so, also was ich mir wünschen würde, wäre halt iCloud, wo ich wüsste, alles klar, das wird irgendwie in meinem Klein verschlüsselt, wird dann da irgendwo gespeichert von mir aus, bei Apple ist es mir egal, weil es ja verschlüsselt, und kommt wieder zurück, aber da kann ich Apple irgendwie auch nicht so richtig trauen, weil die sind einfach viel zu groß und viel zu fit, wenn die das alles für mich machen. Das sind fast so Sachen wie Dropbox, ja, die ich benutze, wenn die sowas machen, das war für mich auch cool. Ja, ich weiß, aber wenn die halt verkacken, dann kick ich die halt und dann nutze ich halt was anderes, aber das ist halt, wenn du alles irgendwie nur noch Apple machst, das geht halt da irgendwie nicht, und das ist mir so ein bisschen, die sind mir zu fett und zu groß.
Ja, es ist vor allen Dingen auch verdammt closed, also...
Ja, und ich würde gerne Alternativen haben, dass ich sagen kann, wenn die Scheiße machen, dann switche ich halt woanders hin. Ist halt irgendwie nicht mehr mit woanders hin, switchen ist vorbei.
Also wenn du halt nur noch zum Beispiel über die Shell dann irgendwie auch noch volle Kontrolle über deine, auf der iCloud mit Shell und so noch rumhacken könntest und deine Files da wieder wegschieben und so weiter, wär nochmal...
Kannst du alles vergessen. Und wie gesagt, demnächst ist vorbei mit Platten tauschen im MacBook Pro, weil dann kommt halt das MacBook Pro Air, da ist dann nichts mehr mit Platte tauschen und dann ist auch nichts mehr mit irgendwie selber Zeug installieren, weil es geht ja auch nur noch inzwischen über den Store, also das geht ja schon in Richtung wie beim iOS. Also bald ist Closed, Closed, Closed.
Da ist der Ofen aus.
Ja, dann will ich mal sehen, wenn du wechselst.
Ich bleib jetzt hier einfach auf diesem...
Vorhin hast du noch gesagt, du wechselst dann. Nee, da hörst du auf mit dem Computer an.
Nee, hier mit Apple-Teufeln.
Da wird die Schreibmaschine wieder...
Nee, ich behalte den Rechner dann einfach mit dem OS und dann ist gut.
Kaufen wir uns einen Commodore Typewriter.
Oder doch Ubuntu?
Naja, das ist halt... Das ist auch scheiße.
Das ist ein Dilemma. Was wir brauchen, sind einfach Kompetitoren. Wir brauchen einfach Wettbewerber.
Weißt du, so ein geiles Unix drunter für Puristen, so ohne viel Kram, so reine leere Unix drunter. Und eine slicky Gui obendrauf und fertig. Und dann hier nicht irgendwie...
Aber wer soll das überhaupt noch zaubern?
Wer soll das noch leisten?
Also Open Source.
Nee, die bringt es nicht. Apple selber müsste. Aber ja.
Apple, ja, keine Ahnung. Man kann eigentlich nur hoffen, dass der Laden dann irgendwann auseinanderfliegt und sich irgendwie in drei Teile teilt.
Also was meine Idee ja wäre, also von mir aus eher Apple. Also ich bin auch gerne bereit, ein bisschen mehr für meine Privacy zu bezahlen. Was ich gerne hätte, was ich bei US-10-Server nie verstanden habe, ist, warum da nicht Dienste dabei sind, wo ich irgendwie zum Beispiel bei dem US-10-Server immer damals für mein iPhone, wo ich mir gleich so einen VPN klicke. Und jetzt muss da eigentlich ein US-10-Server rauskommen, wo nicht eine iCloud drauf ist, sondern so eine Dennis Cloud, meine private Cloud. Vielleicht noch für meine Mami und für was ich noch irgendwie mit draufpasst. Kostet halt so ein bisschen extra, aber ich hab dann halt so meinen eigenen Scheiß. Und warum gibt's sowas nicht? Für Leute, die so ein bisschen mehr irgendwie Self-Control haben wollen.
Die private.
Die müssen dann halt US-10-Server kaufen, ist ja nicht so schlimm. Die zahlen dann halt extra dafür, dass sie ihre Privacy haben.
Ja, aber nicht auf deinem eigenen Computer. Ich mein, das kannst du ja auch in irgendeiner anderen Cloud als Sub-Cloud hosten, wenn das entsprechend kryptographisch abgesichert ist.
Deine eigenen Stunts von iCloud halt, wo du selber Rute hast zur Not und so.
Hätte ich gerne.
denizx.icloud.com Haben sie wahrscheinlich Angst, dass wenn das dann so offen ist, dass dann lauter Firmen kommen und so was selber anbieten und sie dann mit ihrer iCloud irgendwie...
Nee, die werden das den Firmen anbieten. Also ich denke, das ist über worz oder lang...
Haben sie bisher noch nie gemacht, auch irgendwie so iPhone VPN?
Ja, Apple steht am Anfang. Ich meine, Apple ist... Ja, Apple hat jetzt gerade mal seit einem Jahr eine Cloud.
Ja, es gab es doch vorher auch schon andere Sachen. Wie gesagt, iPhone VPN hätten sie da auch schon machen können. Osten Server, Klicks, iPhone VPN, zack, fertig. Für Firmen zum Beispiel. Dass alle irgendwie Mitarbeiter zum Home-Server und VPN connecten.
Ja, aber die Firmen haben eh ihre VPNs. Die haben da ihre Cisco-Boxen stehen, da läuft ein VPN und das iPhone kann da auch sich hin verbinden. Also so what? Den fehlt nichts. Das ist ja überhaupt das einzige Telefon, was alle VPN-Typen so out of the box unterstützt.
Aber eigentlich wäre es doch wahrscheinlich, wenn man das jetzt so mal sich anhört, die Beschwerden, wäre das ja eigentlich von Apple dann so der schönste Move, wenn sie sozusagen ihre ganzen Apis und so weiter einfach so Open Source machen würden, oder? Also ich mein, wir können ja hier in iCloud Schnacken-Fans und alles Mögliche machen, aber es dann halt zumindest so alles aufmachen, dass du als interessierter Entwickler und begeisterter Enthusiast, dann auch die Chance hast, zu gucken, was die denn da eigentlich alles so genau tun.
Open Cloud.
Open Cloud. openmycloud.org, sorry.
Ja, wirf doch schon mal den Compiler an.
Nee, das muss ja nicht heißen, dass jetzt irgendwie du dir auch alles selber machen musst, aber zumindest so ein bisschen Transparenz in das Ganze reinbringen.
Peak Apple sag ich nur. Peak Apple übrigens. Ja, wir sind so ein bisschen fed up.
Auf hohem Niveau auch.
Ja, aber...
Wir gucken ja in die Zukunft und wir sehen halt nichts mehr, was da noch schönes kommt.
Ja, aber das Problem ist ja, wir stehen auf einem Peak von dem aus, gucken wir nur in Taylor. Da ist ja nichts.
Na ja, drum.
Aber das ist auch... Aber jetzt zum Beispiel, wenn du dir die Mountain-Line anguckst, das ist halt irgendwie, es ging halt so die ganze Zeit bergauf und dann so die Krönung, weil der Snow lepert mit wieder so puristisch und wir räumen mal auf, immer alles slick und schnell und snappy und schön und dann jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt wieder der dicke Bloatbär an und klebt jedem irgendwie... Kommt der dicke Bloatbär an und klebt jedem Feature in die Nase und dann irgendwie noch eine API und hier noch ein Notification-Center und da noch eine iCloud und... Wißt schon, so jetzt nimmt das wieder alles so an Ballast und Schwungmasse auf, dass uns alle wie die Titanic in den Abgrund reißen. Also das Ding ist ja, wir sind ja auch immer, wir sehen uns ja auch immer so als diese Mac, also die Pro-User, die Power-User, die irgendwie alles schnell klick klick, zack zack, alles mit Tastatur und so weiter und so fort, muss alles schnell gehen und wir fühlen uns ja vor allen Dingen vernachlässigt, die breite Apple-Masse, die jetzt da gerade irgendwie wie bescheuert iPads und so weiter kauft, die sind ja wahrscheinlich happy.
Das sind doch die Profis von morgen und wenn es vielleicht auch erst noch ein paar Tage später ist, aber die werden doch irgendwann auch schneller arbeiten wollen oder irgendwie, weißte schon, die wachsen ja auch rein. Die Windows-Twitcher von vorgestern.
Naja, aber ich muss sagen, also so alles an Line ist ja auch nicht so schlecht. Also ich muss...
Die Optik.
Die war nicht schlecht in Line.
Dieser Persistent Desktop, der kann schon auch praktisch sein.
Er kann auch ganz schön peinlich in die Hose gehen, wenn er die Fenster zur falschen Zeit aufgehen, weil er gerade frisch boot ist und dann in so ein altes Programm, in so einem alten Bild hochkommt. Aber manchmal denkt man sich schon, uiuiuiui, wenn ich jetzt mal...
Also bei mir, ich habe mich in letzter Zeit über diesen Persistent Desktop sehr gefreut, weil ich spiele, wie schon alle fleißig mitbekommen haben, ja immer Diablo Beta und da crasht es halt manchmal und dann freest der Schirm und ich kann halt nichts mehr, komm nicht mehr raus und das Einzige, was hilft, ist so ein Hot Restart. Nee, es hilft wirklich nichts anderes. Doch? Nein, auch nicht. Foursquid mit Foreground Application, nix. Ja. Also ich könnte rein...
Deckel zu und wieder auf?
Nein, hab ich auch schon probiert.
SSH genau.
Ja, ich könnte noch rein SSH, wenn ich einen anderen Rechner da hatte. Blablabla. ZSH-MS. Auf jeden Fall hab ich jetzt dann irgendwie Hot Restart gemacht, zack und dann war halt plötzlich alles wieder so da. Inklusive Diablo war's Crashed 9, Quatsch. Aber da war das schon ganz cool. Also Browser, Taps, Terminals, alles da und vor allen Dingen in den Terminals ist ja dann immer noch was als letztes so drinsteht, so ausgegraut, ne? Das heißt, du weißt auch noch welches was war und so, das ist schon... Ja, ich hab gesagt ZSH-MS. Hab da richtig gelesen, im Chat.
ZSH-VS.
Ja, also es ist nicht alles schlecht allein, aber es ist...
Vieles schlecht.
Die Tendenz gefällt mir persönlich gar nicht.
Ich find das neue Go schon ziemlich cool, weil ich hab letztens mit Leopard rumgespielt nochmal und das ist schon ganz schön...
Ja, diese riesen Ampel-Mattens, ne?
Ich hab auf meinem Dual-G4 500 MHz einen Leopard installiert und das ist schon ganz schön bunt und candy und rund und sieht ganz schön altbacken und slow aus. Also ist ja mein Rechner auch, aber... Also das sieht bei allein alles schon viel schicker aus.
Aber die GUI hatten sie auch schon bei Snow Leopard, das ist lecker gemacht so ein bisschen, ne?
Sie haben halt die Farbe aus den Icons genommen und sie haben den Fullscreen-Modus einfach verkackt.
Ich glaube, der Fullscreen-Modus ist aber auch wirklich nur fürs R. Für alles andere ist der, glaube ich, auch gar nicht gedacht.
Das ist so ein Mega-Fail.
Ja, aber vorher gab es ja auch Fullscreen-Modi, die jetzt alle, weil jetzt alle auf diesen System Fullscreen-Modus umschalten, wird der Fullscreen-Modus als solcher nicht mehr... ist er generell nicht mehr nützlich, ja, ist einfach die Nützlichkeit.
Der größte Fail bei diesem Fullscreen-Modus, äh, da hab ich mir ja auch, ich hab vor kurzem...
Es gibt einen noch größeren Fail als das Multi-Monitor-Verhalten?
Jajajaj, das ist, aber da bin ich, da bin ich ja auch, da hab ich mir ja eine Facialpalmierung Deluxe verpasst, ja. Hab ich mal wieder eine DVD so gerippt und wollte die halt, ja, weil du kannst...
Du hast was gemacht?
Ich hab die gekauft, ja. Aber ich wollte sie halt irgendwie in Digit, also als Pfeil haben. So, dann pack ich das in den DVD-Player von Apple rein und wollte das halt Beamer und Laptop nebeneinander und dann alle anderen Videoplayer machen, den Zweitbildschirm schwarz, damit halt nichts irgendwie im Raum rumleuchtet und so weiter. Dann machst du DVD-Player an, startest die DVD und dann kommt dieser Fullscreen-Modus und dann ist dieser zweite Bildschirm in diesem komischen, bekackten, texturierten Grau und leuchtet halt durch die Gegel. Warum?
Das ist so ein Fail.
Es gibt null Grund, warum er da diesen bescheuerten Fullscreen-Modus mit diesem grau texturierten, nee.
Ja, dass er dann auch immer den Fullscreen auf einem bestimmten Bildschirm aufmachen will und du gar nicht dann nochmal, also du kannst noch nicht mal, wenn du fünf Bildschirme hast, sagen auf welchen.
Na das, der macht das auf dem, wo dein DVD-Fanster halt ist.
Also wenn das bei DVD so funktioniert, dann toi toi toi, das funktioniert mit iTunes nicht.
Das könnte ich mal probieren, aber.
Und das funktioniert auch mit dem Quicktime-Player nicht, wo es immer so funktioniert.
So oder so war es halt in dem Fall fail. M-Player, VLC, die machen immer schwarz und man kann halt trotzdem noch dann, wenn man die Maus drüber bewegt, dein Menü und noch benutzen und so.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wie sie das Problem mit dem Fullscreen ganz einfach beheben. Sie entfernen einfach den Multi-Monitor-Support. Sagen einfach mehrere Bildschirme, das ist viel zu kompliziert für die Leute, das verwirrt die.
Ich benutze ihn auch nicht.
Also wenn alle Leute einen 30 Zoll Monitor hätten.
Genau, kauft euch den neuen iMac mit 50 Zoll, doubles as a TV. Dann ist das Problem gelöst. Vielleicht ist es so jetzt mit Apple Beyond the Peak.
Mal eine kurze technische Frage. Kann man eigentlich, soll das nicht möglich sein, dass man bei dem Thunderbolt zwei Displays an einen Port stecken kann? Gibt es da für Kabel, Adapter, wie macht man das?
Thunderbolt halt. Du chains die einfach.
Ach, Chaining.
Wie bei Scasi.
Okay, und wenn aber ein bestimmtes Display nur ein Eingang hat?
Du meinst du hast ein Thunderbolt Display ohne Thunderbolt Port?
Also ich brauch immer zwei Thunderbolt Ports am Display, damit das...
Fass doch auf, wenn du ein Thunderbolt Display hast. Es gibt wahrscheinlich nur ein Thunderbolt Display.
Na die Dell Displays, die haben ja Display Port.
Also Thunderbolt kommt bisher immer mit einem extra Port, damit du genau das tun kannst. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Firewire mit den Platten. Es kann halt sein, dass du auch mal eine Platte hast, wo nur einer dran ist, aber...
Aber es gibt kein so Verteiler-Dings, einfach systeminherent nicht.
Das würde ich so nicht sagen. Also im Prinzip, so ein Hub wäre, ich meine, das ist PCI-Bus. Das ist PCIe. Und da kannst du natürlich auch Kaskaden machen. Also das ist, glaube ich, nicht so das Problem. Aber das ist jetzt alles nur Theorie, weil es gibt ja auch keine Thunderbolt-Devices. Kein Thunderbolt-Firewire, kein Thunderbolt-Internet.
Und da würde auch so ein bisschen mehr Open Source sein. Hier, nehmt doch einfach die scheiß Display-Ports weg und baut Displays dafür und kauft euch Max, weil es die einzigen sind, die da irgendwie so ein Port dran haben, ist mir doch alle total egal.
Lassi Hub.
Aber irgendwie dieses auch...
Chipt angeblich jetzt. Lassi Hub heißt das Teil.
Ja, das höre ich seit zwei Jahren, diese News.
Das soll angeblich jetzt chippen.
Lassi Hub.
Ja, das ist das Ding, da kannst du Esata-Drives irgendwie anschließen an das Teil.
Couldn't care less.
Kein Esata.
Can you hear that? That's the sound of me not caring.
Ja, wozu soll das jetzt gut sein? Das ist sozusagen ein alternativer Festplattenanschluss, ein schneller.
Ja, naja, E-Sata ist halt das Schnellste, was momentan geht, weil die Drives machen auch nur Sata.
Ja, und dann mit Thunderbolt, was das Schnellste ist. Und dann hast du sozusagen maximale Plattenperformance.
Genau.
Ich brauche die Verbindung zur Peripheriewelt. Das ist das, was ich von einem Port erwarte. Und das findet derzeit nicht statt.
Eine Anbindung an die Peripheriewelt findet derzeit nicht statt.
So ist es.
Das war eigentlich das Coolste am ganzen Star Wars.
Aber das war auch Peak Star Wars. Das war aber der Moment, wo wir Star Wars am geilsten fanden. Und danach ging es nur noch bergab.
Das Trailer war noch cool so.
Invasion.
Und dann ging es nur noch bergab. Dann kamen JaJaBings.
Das war echt eine der größten kulturellen Enttäuschungen.
Man hat diesen Plop richtig gehört im Kino, als JaJaBings auf die Bühne kam.
So geht es mir so ein bisschen mit dem Fullscreen-Modus.
JaJaBinkisierung von MacOS.
Die ganze Zeit macht so Pschh an meinem Rechner. Der verliert einfach die ganze Zeit Luft, so der Druck. Alles, was sich so über Jahrzehnte aufgestaut hat, alles so Pschh.
Aber es ist wirklich ganz schön heulen auf hohem Niveau, finde ich. Also ich war noch nie so happy mit meinem Rechner wie mit dem hier.
Ja, warte mal bis...
Aber wenn Apple mich nicht glücklich machen kann, dann sollten sie wirklich anfangen, Krisensitzungen einzulösen.
Aber jetzt hört euch mal die letzten 20 Folgen Mobile Max an, und wie oft ihr beide über Leinen geratet habt, ja? Und wie scheiße das ist.
Hast du nicht letzte Woche den Dings gehört hier? War das letzte Woche?
Ja, das Intro. Warst du noch nicht da?
Das war so gut, das sollst du eigentlich nochmal spielen, aber hast du jetzt nicht so schnell drauf, oder? Hast du es drauf?
Ja, wieso nicht?
Wenn es gut ist. Und Hokel das noch nicht kennt.
Und nur für mich?
Und das war wirklich gut, also ich meine.
Ja, das stimmt. Das hab ich hier.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob du auch mit drin erwähnt wurdest.
Na schauen wir mal.
Weiß ich auch nicht, glaub ja.
Ich fand ja allein bisher immer gar nicht so schlecht.
Okay, ich spiel das nochmal ab. Genau, da können wir auch nochmal David preisen, der hier immer schön pünktlich zur nächsten Sendung. Tag vorher ist das in der Mail, jedes Mal großartig.
Wir liegen auf den Knien, so wie in der Moschee.
Ja, was für eine Serie, muss ich sagen. Auch echt super hingelegt.
Flättern sofort.
Genau, flättern sie jetzt. Und auf Soundcloud liegt übrigens sein ganzes Archiv.
Jetzt rück mal auf den Schirm.
Haben die denn da jetzt schon Flatter-Support auf Soundcloud?
Falscher, pp-pp-p-p.
Ja, kommt davon. Alles nicht geplant hier, ne? Aber jetzt geht's los.
März 2011.
Man, man, man.
Da hat sich was getan.
Da hat sich was getan, ja.
Also alle, die berichten, sagen snappy, snappy, snappy.
Das ist ein fantastischer Computer. Und das merken, glaube ich, gerade auch eine ganze Menge.
Das ganze Internet ist von diesem Eindruck überzeugt. Das flutscht einfach.
Zwölf Monate später Ich wollte überhaupt in meinem Leben immer nur einen einzigen Computer.
Den besten.
Alle anderen interessieren mich gar nicht.
Da kann man es eigentlich nur...
Vor allem die Musik am Anfang.
Da kann man...
Auf den Punkt, wo ich sage.
Kann man eigentlich nur noch mit... Nee, ich zitiere doch nicht. Pfeife, das mag bestimmt die halbe Zuhörerschaft nicht. Pfeife hat ja dieses... Es gibt ja von Pfeife... von Pfeife gibt es ja dieses... diese Quotes aus dem Usenet. Pfeifes Produktbewertung. Eine epische Zusammenstellung. Also das kann man sich als Fortune-File auch gerne in die Scheln sehen. Seine üblichste Bewertung ist halt irgendwie so, weiß nicht, Python-Tonne, oder? Und das wäre jetzt auch so Lion-Tonne, ne? Ich suche mal den Link raus, weil der ist echt ganz großartig. Nee, aber das, ja genau. Sowas könnte man eigentlich öfter machen, aber ich glaube, wir machen das, wir machen solche Sachen öfter mal. So über lange Zeit erst so über den grünen Knäloben und dann hinterher in den Boden stampfen, rammen.
Hier wird alles seiner Qualität entsprechend behandelt.
Das waren halt so gesehen Vorschusslorbeeren, andere Leute machen sowas gar nicht, die hauen gleich drauf.
Nicht auszudecken. Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt den Link finde.
Hier wird jetzt noch mal dieser, wo wir noch so ein bisschen bei der Glaskugel sind, ihr habt sicherlich auch diesen Artikel gesehen über diesen Menschen, der diese Gerüchte mit dem 7,85 Zoll Bildschirm aufgegriffen hat.
Wie groß ist jetzt gerade der Bildschirm vom iPad?
9,7.
Der jetzige ist 9,7, also knapp 10.
War schon immer so.
Und der redet jetzt von knapp 8 oder so.
7,85.
Ich glaub kein Wohl.
Naja, das interessante ist...
Das müsste so Kindelgröße sein dann.
Naja, es gibt einen anderen Aspekt. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob ich jetzt aus dem Kopf die ganzen Rechnungen nachvollziehen kann. Aber erstmal davon ausgegangen, was wäre, wenn man die alte Auflösung des iPad 1 und 2, nämlich 1024 x 768, auf 7,85 Inch runterschwingt?
Also sozusagen die DPI ein bisschen steigt, oder?
Ja, die DPI steigen dadurch natürlich. Aber du nimmst die selber. Aber die alte Größe ist ein bisschen kleiner. Also wenn du das 1024 x 768 von dem alten iPad nimmst und zusammenstauchst auf 7,85, was jetzt deutlich kleiner ist, als das man jetzt von den Zahlen her erwarten würde, weil es halt die Diagonal ist, dann hast du exakt die DPI des iPhone, das 163 DPI. Also es entspricht exakt. Also diese Zahl ist von daher so interessant zum Gedankenspiel, weil wenn man halt die iPad-Pixel-Anzahl auf diese Größe reduziert, erhältst du die iPhone-Auflösung, die Prerithinia-Auflösung.
Ja, aber so viel Unterschied ist das doch gar nicht, oder? Das sind da irgendwie 20% weniger.
Ja, aber das heißt, dass du quasi mit den iPhone-Grafiken und User-Interface-Elementen, ohne irgendwelche Resize-Geschichten machen zu müssen, selben Touch-Targets hast. Also du hast dann nach wie vor diese 44 x 44 Pixel sind dann sozusagen die Touch-Größe, so wie es eben auch beim iPhone war, nur weil das Ganze größer ist. Der ganze Punkt, den er macht, ist letzten Endes, dass das eine interessante Variante ist in dieser generellen Überlegung mit, müsste es noch mal etwas zwischen einem iPhone und einem iPad geben. Dass er sagt, wenn es sowas gäbe, dann wäre diese Zahl 7,85 dahingehend interessant, weil man ja eben auch bei diesen ganzen Minitabletts immer eher so in diesem 7-8 Zoll Bereich.
Okay, sie würden es dann aber wahrscheinlich direkt als Retina bauen.
Naja, sein Argument war in dem Moment, dass das eben eine Technologie ist, diese Auflösung, dass sie diese Bildschirme halt extrem günstig herstellen können. Also dass das eben etwas ist, wo sie die ganze Toolchain schon für haben. Also solche Bildschirmauflösungen zu machen, das ist ja so, wenn die jetzt ein neues iPad bauen, dann kaufen sie dafür Geräte, die bestücken die ganzen Maschinen. Apple ownt das ja auch. Man hat immer so dieses Bild, dass sie dann nach Taiwan gehen und sagen, guten Tag, baut uns das mal. Tatsächlich ist es so, die kaufen zwar diese Dienstleistung dort ein, aber diese Fabrik, die da entsteht, das ist ja für Apple. Und das ist quasi so eine outgesourcete Fabrik, aber Apple kauft auch dieses ganze Gerät, auch dieses Milling für die Unibuddies etc. Das sind ja Geräte, die nur Apple benutzt. Ist nicht so, dass so eine Taiwan-Firma, die dann so kauft und dann könnte auch Dell kommen und sich sowas auch mal bauen. Nee, das ist alles Apples. Und das sind halt ihre Investitionen. Gab es mal bei Amesimco auch eine schöne Aufstellung, wo immer so diese Investitionskurve in diesem Gerätepark für die Produktion extrem ansteigt, immer so ein halbes Jahr, dreiviertel Jahr, bevor dann das Big Release ist. Und diese Geräte sind halt da und sie können die über Jahre verwenden, um ein Gerät zu bauen. Sie bauen jetzt auch immer noch iPhone 3GS. Das wird verkauft, das wird gebaut, das ist immer noch dasselbe Equipment.
Ja, aber sie müssen ja trotzdem eine neue Art von Display bauen.
Ja, aber die Technologie, um diese DPI's zu bauen, das ist sozusagen etwas, was schon...
Ja, aber die machen die doch nicht einzeln drauf. Es ist ja wieder ein ganz anderes Display.
Ja, es ist ein anderes Display, aber es ist die Webtechnologie, es ist halt einfach diese 163 DPI. Das ist halt einfach...
Überzeugt mich jetzt nicht so, muss ich sagen.
Ich will dich davon gar nicht überzeugen. Ich sag nur, es ist ein interessantes Gedankenspiel unter dem Aspekt, dass sie eben Equipment in vielerlei Hinsicht weiterverwenden können, als auch Programmierer eben auch es einfacher hätten so etwas zu targeten. Ob das wirklich kommt, keine Ahnung.
Was ich viel spannender fand, war das Gedankenexperiment. Was ist eigentlich aus den Gerüchten zu dem iPhone, nennen wir es iPhone 5, dass als nächstes kommen dann irgendwie, dass das ein neues Display kriegt und das Display größer ist, obwohl sie den Formfaktor des Telefons beibehalten. Und da hat irgendjemand ausgerechnet, ja, wie wäre das denn, wenn man das Display länger macht? Ja, also das Telefon bleibt von der Gesamtbreite so wie es ist, aber du machst oben und unten noch ein paar Pixel dran und hast dann irgendwie nicht mehr drei zu zwei oder was das ist, sondern irgendwie halt mehr.
Und dann?
Und dann hättest du das Ding, dass du als Programmierer, also ich meine auf dem iPhone ist sowieso fast alles nur ein Tableview, machst du halt einfach mehr Tableview drauf und du kannst das Programm ohne größere Änderungen eigentlich auf dem neuen Display laufen lassen und musst jetzt keine großen Umstände machen. Was anderes wäre halt, wenn du jetzt das auch breiter machen würdest?
Ja, aber das ganze, denk mal an Spiele, das ganze Artwork.
Spiele ist was anderes, da hast du halt den Trauerrand, aber das ist ja...
Warum sollten sie das machen? Ist ja ehrlich gesagt keine Notwendigkeit. Ich denke nicht, dass ihr Produkt dadurch besser wird, dass es jetzt nochmal einen Zentimeter hoch und runter.
Also ich glaube, das würde wirklich, also für iPhone Programmierer wäre es wirklich easy, weil wenn es Tableviews, machst du gar nichts. Eigentlich fast sogar eine Breite, wenn du bestimmte Sachen rechtsbündig hast, passiert dir auch nicht doll viel, dann hast du halt ein bisschen mehr Platz. Also wenn du richtig gut code ist und sehr vorausschauend code ist, dann müsste man eigentlich fast gar nichts machen. Ansonsten, wenn sie sagen, das kommt jetzt so, sind die alle relativ schnell dabei und haben es gefixt. Und wenn es nur die Höhe ist, dann auf jeden Fall. Aber ob es wirklich Sinn macht, weiß ich auch nicht, wegen so ein paar Pixel. Was sind das? Wie viele Pixel sind das, die du nach oben und unten gewinnt oder nur nach oben?
Du hast dann aber, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, hast du halt eine 16 zu 9 Seitenverhältnis und könntest dann aber die Filme in 16 zu 9 auch füllend gucken. Ja, das war die Argumentation von demjenigen, der das irgendwie, der dir das Gedankenspiel gemacht hat.
Da winken wir ab, sag ich mal.
Ja, glaube ich nicht so. Also ich glaube, es würde gehen und es wäre jetzt technisch nicht so schwer und die Programmierer würden auch nicht allzu doll stöhnen, weil wie gesagt, es wäre ganz easy für die, dass sie sich da anpassen, aber ja.
Also zu dem kleineren iPad, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass sie das machen, weil da vielleicht noch ein Markt ist, irgendwas zwischen iPad und iPhone, aber diese Argumentation, das ist jetzt genau die gleiche Auflösung und deswegen haben sie die Maschinen schon da, das kommt ein bisschen komisch vor, aber vielleicht hast du da recht, ja.
Apple bringt kein Produkt raus, weil sie dann noch Maschinen da haben.
Nein, aber es ist etwas, was ihnen erlaubt, etwas extrem günstig zu produzieren. Also gerade wenn sie jetzt, sagen wir mal, mit so was wie dem Kindle, sollten sie aus irgendwelchen Gründen meinen, sie müssten in diese Kategorie gehen, weil da ist irgendwie Geld zu holen. Und ich glaube, wenn sie in der Lage sind, ein Produkt zu produzieren, was ihnen ihre Marge bietet, die sie gerne haben möchten, die ja nicht niedrig ist, wie wir alle wissen, und sie sind in der Lage, da ein Produkt reinzusetzen, was ihrer Meinung nach, und im Idealfall natürlich auch der Meinung nach der potenziellen Kunden, irgendwie sinnvoll ist, eine sinnvolle Ergänzung ist des iOS-Geräteparks. Dann gibt es halt Zeichen dafür, dass sie da eben auch sehr wohl in der Lage sind, extrem günstig zu produzieren, weil das einfach für sie keine Neuigkeit ist. Da muss nicht viel erfunden werden, da muss keine riesen Multimedialen Investitionen in die Hand genommen werden, um überhaupt erstmal diesen Gerätepark herzustellen, um das zu produzieren. Das ist nicht unerheblich, weil es muss halt irgendwie gehen. So, wenn das 3GS jetzt irgendwie ausläuft demnächst, ich meine, das wird jetzt im September, wenn dann ein neues iPhone kommt, dann wird das 3GS wegfallen.
Vielleicht.
Dann ist das iPad 2 das einzige Bildschirm noch mit Lores im iOS-Bereich. Und da wird halt was frei.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das 3GS so lange weiter produziert wird, wie das aktuelle iOS da drauf läuft. Und wenn...
Läuft dann das 6er dann noch da drauf?
Ja, das wird man dann sehen.
Ist nicht das 6er jetzt für das iPhone 4 schon das Letzte?
Wir haben keine Erkenntnisse, worauf es läuft.
Naja, das iPhone 4 hat ja glaube ich schon doppelt so viel Speicher wie das 3GS. Und das ist natürlich der Punkt, wo Apple dann sagen könnte, das nächste iOS ist wieder ein bisschen dicker geworden und jetzt schmeißen wir das 3GS über Bord.
Ja, das 6er wird gar nicht auf dem 3GS laufen, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Und meine Voraussage ist halt einfach, solange das aktuelle iOS auf dem 3GS läuft, werden sie es auch weiter verkaufen. Gut, also vier gleichzeitig Produkte, wahrscheinlich dann doch nicht, aber...
Weiß man nicht. Das sein kann nicht sein. Ich ehrlich gesagt denke, dass das irgendwann ist es einfach nicht mehr so attraktiv. Entscheidend sind die Economies auf Scale, aber sie können mittlerweile auch ein iPhone 4 wahrscheinlich verdammt billig produzieren. Und ob das 3GS ihnen dann noch so viel Freude macht. Irgendwann ist es halt auch eine Spaßbremse im Hinsicht auf neue Features, mit denen sie Kunden gewinnen wollen etc. Weil es dann einfach zu langsam ist.
Von der Logik her würde das iOS 6 auf dem 3GS nicht mehr laufen.
Von Dennis Logik her natürlich.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen, dass sie, wenn sie jetzt sagen, wir nehmen nur noch Geräte, die ein halbes Gigabyte RAM haben, dass sie dann halt auch frei atmen können und nochmal ganz andere Features einbauen können. Da fällt dann glaube ich auch das iPad 1 hinten runter.
Meint eigentlich, das kommt beim iPhone 5, wenn wir es jetzt mal so nennen, ein neues Gehäuse, oder weil es so schick war, nochmal hier so gleich wie vorher.
Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie nochmal das gleiche Gehäuse nehmen, weil das einfach, damit es wieder nach was Neuem aussieht, muss ein neues Gehäuse her. Also, meine Einschätzung der Sache. Ob das Gehäuse jetzt schicker wird oder nicht, das werden wir dann sehen, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie nochmal das gleiche Gehäuse nehmen. Du hattest halt dieses 3G-Gehäuse, 3G S war das gleiche Gehäuse. Du hattest das 4G Gehäuse, 4S war das gleiche Gehäuse. Wenn jetzt ein 5 kommt oder wie auch immer es dann heißen wird, the new iPhone, dann wird es sicherlich ein neues Gehäuse haben. Also, kann ich mir nicht anders vorstellen. Aber, also ehrlich gesagt, so ein kleineres iPad fände ich total cool, wenn es dann auch entsprechend viel leichter wäre.
Das wird es ja wohl sein, oder?
Weil das wäre für mich ein Killer-Feature, wenn sie es schaffen, irgendwie auf 60% des Gewichts zu kommen.
Aber für mich wäre es wiederum, ich wollte vorhin auch gar nichts vertreten, ich persönlich bin durch mit Non-Retina.
Also, ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht mehr ein Gerät mit 160 dpi, das habe ich aber auch nicht gesagt, dass ich für 60% des Gewichts des Non-Retina nochmal kaufen würde. Das würde ich auch so nicht sagen, nein, nein.
Aber so Hi-Res, so wie das neue iPad, bloß in kleiner wäre für dich interessant?
Auf jeden Fall, klar. Also mal ganz ehrlich, wenn du Bücher lesen willst, oder wenn du überhaupt Sachen lesen willst, also auf dem iPad ist es ja vor allen Dingen nur deswegen als Non-Retina-erträglich, weil es ja so groß ist, dann kann man es weiter weghalten und die Welt ist wieder in Ordnung. Und wenn man das Gerät jetzt entsprechend kleiner macht und hat aber Retina da drauf, dann kann man da, glaube ich, wunderbar Bücher mit lesen, ohne dass man wirklich das richtig große iPad dazu braucht. Das könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Das ist ja das, was der Kindle macht.
Ja, im Wesentlichen. Ja gut, der Kindle ist natürlich nochmal viel leichter, weil er ja dieses komische Gyro-Dings da, e-Paper-Display hat.
Aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube nicht so richtig an diese 7-Zoll-Geschichte. Gerade auch im Hinblick auf diese iBooks. Ich hab jetzt diese iBooks das erste Mal getestet, weil es lief ja am Anfang auf dem iPad 1 gar nicht so richtig.
Diese animierten iBooks.
Ja, ja. Ich muss sagen, das fand ich schon cool. Das fand ich echt überzeugend. Da war auch so die Navigation sinnvoll gelöst, nicht wie bei diesen ganzen Apps, die sich so allerlei flashhaftigen Schabernack da in der Navigation immer einfallen lassen, wo man immer nicht weiß, wo man ist. So mit Hoch- und Runterblättern und so weiter. Von links nach rechts die Kapitel, von oben nach unten die Seiten in dem Kapitel. Das verfängt einfach überhaupt nicht. Du weißt nie so richtig, wo du bist. Das haben die da deutlich besser gelöst. Und auch diese ganze Art und Weise, wie du diese interaktiven Elemente aus diesem Begleitkästchen rausholst, das ist schon irgendwie überzeugend. Und ich wüsste nicht so recht, wie sowas auf so einem 7-Zoll-Teil wiederum skaliert. Also, ich denke, wir werden kein 7-Zoll-iPod sehen dieses Jahr. Ich denke, wir werden kein...
Ein iPod war ein schöner Versprecher...
.iPad, wir werden kein Fernseher sehen. Wir werden wahrscheinlich auch kein MacBook Air mit 3G sehen, aber so ist es denn passiert, nehme ich alles zurück. Und wir werden das 15-Zoll-Macbook Pro sterben sehen gegen einen R. Das 17er wird in Full-Bloat und Vollausbau mit allen Steckern und Buttons und Löchern, was es alles hat und Festplatten und so weiter.
Und seinen gloriosen zweieinhalb Kilo.
Genau, und kommt dann aber vielleicht auch noch in Retina. 17-Zoll in Retina Overkill mit dem besten Kontrast ever. Und alle Grafiker sind glücklich und werden sich dieses fette Teil kaufen und irgendwie glücklich fünf Kilo durch die Gegend schleppen. Und was haben wir noch? Mac Pro, 19-Zoll Rack. Ich bin dafür, aber ich wäre auch nicht überrascht, wenn der Formfaktor einfach derselbe bleibt. Haben wir noch eine Produktgeneration vergessen? HiMac könnte dünner werden.
Interessant finde ich ja, dass sie beim Mac Mini dann doch irgendwann den Formfaktor so geändert haben, dass man wirklich zwei Mac Minis in eine Höhen-Einheit, 19-Zoll Rack, reinkriegt. Das fand ich ja schon dann recht cool irgendwie. Also der aktuelle Formfaktor ist ja so, dass du zwei Mac Minis nebeneinander in eine Höhen-Einheit, 19-Zoll Rack bekommst.
Nebeneinander. Wie nur zwei Mac Minis in eine HE?
In eine HE, ja. Die alten Mac Minis waren ja zu dick, die hast du ja nicht in eine HE reingekriegt. Ja, da ist noch Platz, aber immerhin hast du nur eine HE. Und dann auch noch ohne Netzteil, weil das Netzteil ist ja mit dem Mac Mini drin. Also so gesehen, keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt vielleicht überbewertet, das so zu sehen, aber da könnte ich mir auch ein Mac Pro, wenn es, na meinetwegen, auch zwei Höhen-Einheiten. Das, was ich jetzt als eine bezeichnet habe, ist aber, glaube ich, nur eine halbe.
Aber wo Tim gerade hier diesen 7 Zoll iPod meinte, hier meine Freundin hat kürzlich ihren alten iPod, der hier die letzte, also Clickwheel noch und so, wissen schon, den 80 Gigabyte iPod mit Clickwheel.
Der 5. oder 5. Generation oder 6. Generation?
Ich glaube, 5. Und dann hab ich den Ding mal wieder in die Hand genommen und hab mal so ein bisschen rumgeklickt und gescrollt. Und ich muss echt sagen, das ist noch immer ein echt geiles Produkt.
Also das Ratten schnell.
Das Ratten schnell navigiert sich so super mit diesem Clickwheel. Das ist echt, das war puristisches Apple Design und Form und Funktion, wie es besser fast nicht geht. Also das war wirklich ein Top-Rät, sag ich mal. Also, hätte ich auch nicht gedacht, ich dachte so, okay, jetzt so einen alten iPod in die Hand nehmen, nachdem jetzt hier irgendwie iPhone, Retina und so weiter und so fort. Aber nee, für Musikplayer ist es genau, einfach genau richtig. Die Krönung der Schöpfung.
Ich hätte ja gern so ein iPhone, wo hinten ein Wheel drauf ist. Ich weiß, dass das wahrscheinlich so...
Jetzt hast du das gesagt und kein Patent drauf. Stupido.
Das wär was. Ich will einfach in meine Tasche greifen und irgendwie scrollen. Oder so ein Clickwheel, hier so als Krawattennadel oder irgendwie sowas. Einfach so externalisieren und dann ins Headphonekabel integrieren. Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu fett. Oder so ein Touchpad. Einfach so ein Mini-Touch, auf dem man irgendwie sowas Ähnliches machen kann. Wheel wäre eigentlich das Gleiche. So in der Größe von so einem Pizzaschneider.
Das ist ja die Größe vom iPod, ne?
So ein Pizzaschneider, merke ich gerade, ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Simulation.
Die gibt es auch in verschiedener Größe. Da wo wir heute die Pizza geholt haben, der Pizzaschneider ist eher so groß wie eine Schallplatte.
Ich könnte mir einfach so einen Pizzaschneider in die Tasche legen und das Gefühl haben, es würde ein iPod-View sein.
Dann darfst du auch nicht falsch auf den Arsch fallen.
Sind wir mit diesem Thema ansonsten durch? Ich hätte noch ein bisschen was.
Ja, Glaskohl können wir mal jetzt hier schließen.
Und zwar noch zwei Sachen aus der Kategorie Spiele. Nein, nicht Diablo 3. Aber kürzlich als ich Diablo 3 spielte, kam jemand an und meinte, es gäbe ein Spiel für Google Chrome. Und dann hab ich so erstmal die Nase gerümpft und die Augenbraue gezückt. Und ich dachte, wie jetzt ein Spiel für Chrome? Ja, in Chrome könne man jetzt halt irgendwie sich so Apps auch installieren aus diesem Chrome-Dingsbums. Keine Ahnung was. Okay, das Spiel heißt auf jeden Fall Bastion, also Bastion geschrieben. Und man muss in der Tat, kann man das dann im Chrome so sich als Up-Downloaden. Ich mach das mal hier an, damit die werten Kollegen zumindest mal sehen, wie das aussieht. Und das ist echt ein ziemlich fettes Spiel dafür, dass es dann letztendlich im Browser läuft und wahrscheinlich mit WebGL oder keine Ahnung, was für Schnuffi implementiert ist. Und es hat halt echt coolen Soundtrack, coole Grafiken, ist von Warner Brothers Games. Also hier Bastion, das Spitze, wird auch schon gelobt. Ich muss mal gleich noch einen Link dazu finden. Was für eine Art von Spiel ist das denn? Also es gibt von Now. Warte mal, bevor du dich hier siehst. Du kannst mir gleich mal bei der Kategorisierung von dieser Art Spiel helfen. Also es ist so ein bisschen, du läufst halt durch Levels, ist so isometrische Ansicht, aber schon 3D und du kannst das ganze Environment smaschen und ja, du musst erzählen ein bisschen Story. Ich sag ja mal, ist so ein Tipp für Leute, die so coole Spiele auch mal im Browser und so weiter. Bastian ist da schon.
Also für Max. Der ist doch immer der große Browser-Verfechter hier. Heute nicht da.
Strategiespiel wird hier gesagt. Na ja, auf jeden Fall, guck mal, du kannst jetzt hier halt so rumlaufen, dann baut sich hier auch so live das Level zusammen und dann kriegst du irgendwann deine Waffe und das ist auch alles, die Story ganz schick erzählt und ein cooler Soundtrack. Muss man kämpfen oder muss man Rätsel finden? Nee, kommt auch noch später mit kämpfen und so.
Ist das mit Prinzessin oder ist das, wo wir alle umbringen wollen?
Ich bin noch nicht so weit gekommen, dass da eine Prinzessin kommt.
Also muss man nur alle umbringen.
Naja, du musst auch so ein bisschen... Ja, der erzählt dir eigentlich...
Also so ein Auto ist nicht dabei.
Er erzählt dir halt im Hintergrund auch noch die ganze Zeit eine Geschichte und jetzt hast du halt hier deinen Hammer gefunden und dann kannst du hier anfangen irgendwie auch hier rumzukloppen und deinen Weg freizuhauen und auszuweichen und so weiter und so fort. Und die Message ist eigentlich nur, folgt den Links in den Show-Notes, guckt euch mal Bastion an. Ist schon auf jeden Fall mal so ein neuer Meilenstein, was so im Browser geht, würde ich schon sagen. Also ein fetteres Spiel im Browser habe ich jetzt zumindest nicht in Erinnerung. So und das zweite Spiel, wir waren ja vorhin bei Indie und so und One-Man-Show-Erfolge. Dann ist natürlich Minecraft ja immer so ein Kandidat für Erwähnung, weil der Typ hat ja mittlerweile irgendwie acht Millionen Euro mit dem Ding verdient und plötzlich... Doch. Noch mehr, okay. Zwanzig, okay, hat letztens drei Millionen an seine fünf Mitarbeiter ausgeschüttet, so als kleines... Und jetzt baut er in dem nächsten Spiel. Es hat einen etwas sperrigen Namen, aber es hat ein extrem cooles Konzept und das heißt 0x10. Die URL findet man hier auch natürlich im Chat. Davon gibt es noch nicht viel zu sehen, aber die Story ist ganz cool und zwar ist die Story, dass im Jahre 1988 irgendwie so eine Long-Sleep-Zell entwickelt wurde und die ist irgendwie Big-Endian und der Computer ist aber Little-Endian und eigentlich sollte die nur ein Jahr schlafen lassen, aber dadurch, dass es halt dann verdreht wurde, wurde aus einem Jahr halt Milliarden, Millionen, was auch immer Jahre. Das heißt, die Leute, die dann da eingeschlefert wurden, die wachen halt irgendwie in einem total auseinandergezerrten Universum auf, alles schon wieder tausendmal zu Asche und verfallen und wieder auferstanden. Außer sie selber und ihrem Raumschiff. Und auf diesem Raumschiff ist eine komplette 16-Bit-CPU, also komplett emuliert sozusagen. Und es gibt eine Spezifikation dafür und man kann die Standardfunktion von diesem Computer mit dieser 16-Bit-CPU benutzen, um seinen Raumschiff zu steuern, die Schilde hochzufahren, irgendwie Planeten abzugrasen oder Gegner anzugreifen. Aber man kann eben auch entweder seine eigenen Spiele da drin bauen oder ein eigenes Betriebssystem. Und es haben auch schon Leute getan. Bei GitHub gibt es jetzt seit kurzem eine Syntax-Spezifikation für den Assembler. Es gibt ein LLVM-Backend, um aus C-Code diesen 16-Bit-Assembler zu compilen. Es gibt einen Kernel schon, der in diesen 16-Bit-Assembler dafür gebaut wurde. Und die Leute gehen jetzt schon, obwohl es noch das Spiel überhaupt nicht gibt, nur weil die Spezifikation für diese CPU draußen ist, gehen die schon total ab und bauen allen möglichen Scheiß.
Moment, da kann ich noch was zu sagen. Einer von diesen, die immer die iPhones aufmachen, wie heißen denn die? Keine Ahnung. iPhone Dev Team. Der hat... Muscle Nerd oder was? Nee, Muscle Nerd war es glaube ich nicht. Aber einer von denen, der hat eine Gegenspezifikation geschrieben und hat haarklein auseinandergenommen, was die Probleme an dieser CPU sind und warum man dafür keinen vernünftigen C-Compiler schreiben kann und welche Bugfixes er gerne in der CPU hätte, damit das Teil sinnvolle Dinge tun kann. Also eins der Probleme ist zum Beispiel, das ist eine reine 16-Bit-CPU, die kann keine Bytes adressieren, sondern nur ganze 16-Bit-Worte. Was, wenn man mit Texten umgehen muss, mit Strings oder so, unglaublich unangenehm ist.
Das Problem, was man bei einem RAID 5 hat, die müssen dann sozusagen immer erst was einlesen, um dann die eine Hälfte davon zu ändern, nämlich einen Byte und dann wieder beide Bytes wegzuschreiben.
Du kannst ja alle Strings, alles so UTF 16 machen.
Das könntest du natürlich machen.
Das wär eh mal ein bisschen.
Also es war so eins von den Sachen. Der hat da noch so ein paar andere Sachen draufgelistet.
Aber es sieht doch ganz stark nach einer 68K CPU aus, oder? So Big Engine, Program-Counter, Stack-Counter.
Achso, und dann hat er noch gemeint, das Ding hat zu wenig Register.
Nämlich nur acht.
Nur acht.
Da hätten wir früher, in unserer Jugend, hätten wir geweint.
Ich weiß, haben wir auch.
Aber der 68K hat acht Datenregister und acht Adresse.
Das Ding ist, das Raumschiff startet halt 1988. Also das ist sozusagen die Spezifikation aus dem Jahre 1988.
Es war nicht total lustig, dass der gleich meine Gegenspezifikation geschrieben hat.
Und er hat es ja auch so früh veröffentlicht, bevor überhaupt irgendwas von dem Spiel da ist, damit er auch schnell Feedback kriegt wahrscheinlich. Aber wie gesagt, es gibt ein LLVM-Backend, um aus C-Code diesen Assembler zu compilen. Also es ist schon getan, der Job. Und wenn du dir das Projekt für dieses LLVM-Backend an der Riste sitzt, nicht nur so ein Fall mit so ein bisschen Food drin, sondern so richtig ein Projekt, da hat sich schon einer ordentlich Mühe gegeben. Also auf jeden Fall dieses Spiel sollte man wahrscheinlich auch noch mal auf der Beobachtungsliste haben, bis es irgendwie was Richtiges zu sehen gibt.
Also, ja. Ich hab da auch noch so ein kleines Ding. Also ich hab das Spiel zwar schon runtergeladen, aber noch nicht gespielt. Insofern ist es nicht wirklich ein Tipp. Aber irgendwie im iTunes-Store auf der Titelseite gab es da irgendwie ein Spiel, das heißt Fibble.
Fibble?
Beziehungsweise auch andere Fibble. Erstaunlich fand ich an diesem Spiel, vor allen Dingen, wer es gemacht hat.
Wer hat es erfunden?
Das ist diese deutsche Bude aus Bochum, oder wo die sind. Die dieses Far Cry und Crisis, also diese richtig blutigen Fies Shooter machen. Machen da jetzt so ein Spiel, das sieht so ein bisschen nach Kinderzimmer-Romantik und mit irgendeinem Alien, der da so rumhüpft und irgendwelche Sachen. Wie gesagt, ich hab's noch nicht gespielt. Tut mir leid, ich kann jetzt da nicht wirklich drüber reden. Ich fand es nur lustig, dass die im App Store sind mit einem Spiel, was so knuttelig knuffig ist.
Die haben halt auch so viel Kohle und machen halt auch Diversifizierung.
Naja, und sie haben einen guten Renderer gebaut, also gebraut.
Also Crysis hat einen der besten Renderer, wenn nicht der beste Renderer, oder? Die Crysis-Spiele, also optisch sind die...
Ganz vorne dabei, seh ich auch so, ja. Fand ich nur irgendwie erstaunlich, dass die dann sowas machen. Weil das halt irgendwie... Könnte nicht weiter weg sein von Crysis.
Ich hab ja auch mir als alter Tower-Defense-Spieler mal ein neues Tower-Defense, nachdem ich die letzten jetzt schon alle wieder durch hab, dieses Jelly-Defense mal runtergeleitet. Das ist mir eigentlich zu süß. Aber die Grafik da ist auch ziemlich fett. Also wir haben es schon echt ganz cool hinbekommen. Und noch ein Tipp. Und zwar hat meine Freundin nach einem Schachprogramm gesucht, mit dem man so mal ein bisschen so seine Skills schärfen kann. So ein bisschen irgendwie so bestimmte Situationen erkennen und so weiter. Und es gibt ja so ein paar Schachprogramme, die sind auch alle so... Und da gibt es eine Serie von Programmen, das heißt Made in Two, Made in One gibt es glaube ich auch, und Made in Three. Also Schach in ein, zwei oder in drei Zügen. Und da ist eine unglaubliche Liste von bestimmten Situationen und du musst sozusagen herausfinden, welche zwei Züge jetzt zum Schachmatt führen. Und wer sowas gerne mal auch ausprobieren will und Puzzle sowieso ganz cool findet, weil du probierst halt viel aus und dann siehst du, das geht jetzt nicht und dann probierst du nochmal. Das ist auch für Puzzle-Freunde ganz gut. Ich paste mal hier den Link kurz in den Chat. Ja, Mate in 2 Puzzles, genau.
Mate in 2, 3, 3, 2, 1.
Genau, 1, 2, 3. Warte, warte, Moment. Und dann gibt es halt noch so zwei, also da gibt es noch natürlich diverse Schachprogramme. Und dieses T-Chess Pro, das ist halt so das Programm, das wohl so ein bisschen die beste Schach-Engine hat. Also meine Freundin hat so ein Schachprogramm davor gespielt, hat dauernd gewonnen. Dann hat sie den installiert und dann irgendwie, egal wie oft noch Andu gemacht wurde, der hat da so richtig einem, ja, das Schachbrett um die Ohren gehauen. Also wenn man eine richtige Schach-Challenge braucht und irgendwie so.
Aber die haben eine ab für wie viele Schritte?
Nee, das sind tausende Puzzles. Das ist wirklich, also vieles ist made in two. Also nur Schach in zwei Schritten. Gibt's hunderte verschiedene Positionen und Puzzle, die du ausprobieren kannst. Das ist eine ab mit wirklich erstmal.
Aber es ist immer in zwei Schritten, anstatt eine abzuhaben, wo man sagen kann, ich möchte in einem, zwei oder mal in drei.
So sieht's wohl aus. Ja, das ist, ja gut, das kann man kritisieren natürlich, aber für 79 Cent andererseits ist auch okay.
Alles Kritisierungswürdige muss kritisiert werden.
Gut, so, das ist jetzt alles verlinkt und verchattet. Also T-Chess Pro.
Wie ist das zweite T-Chess Pro?
Ja, das linke ich hier auch nochmal kurz rein. Das hat auch so ganz viel Analyse und Hilfe, aber die Features sind halt nicht so cool. Aber 1250 Puzzles sind da drin. Naja, also dieses T-Chess Pro, das ist halt so, wenn man mal einen ordentlichen Computer braucht, also einen ordentlichen Computergegner, dann kann man sich damit mal so richtig ausknocken. So, jetzt Dennis.
Meine Kumpels spielen gerade ein Spiel, das heißt Braid. Ist schon ziemlich alt, erzählen sie mir gerade. Aber die spielen das halt, sah ganz witzig aus.
Braid? Schreibt sich wie?
Na wie Raid mit einem B vorne.
Ich hab's auch immer nur im App-Store gesehen.
Ja, und die lustige Idee da, weißt du, dass du halt mit so einem Figürchen so lang rennst und wenn du, also du stirbst nicht, oder also doch, du kannst schon sterben, aber um halt weiterspielen zu können, kannst du die Zeit zurückdrehen. Dann kommst du sozusagen kurz davor, bevor du gestorben bist und kannst dann weiterspielen und halt was anderes machen. Also du kannst halt die Zeit manipulieren. Und das Witzige ist, dass bestimmte Sachen in diesen Levels, das kommt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen später in den Levels, die lassen sich von der Zeit nicht manipulieren, die bleiben halt dann einfach liegen und gehen mit der Zeit nicht mit, wenn du die Zeug spurst. Und gerade dadurch kannst du gewisse Rätsel lösen, indem du halt mit der Zeit spielen musst. Und das ist eigentlich ein ganz cooler Ansatz. Und wenn Leute so auf so eine Rätsel Bock haben, dann können sie sich das ja mal angucken. Also im App Store gibt es auf jeden Fall. Aber in Steam, glaube ich auch, bin ich mir aber jetzt nicht so sicher. Aber ich glaube schon. Ja, könnt ihr mal gucken. Ist ganz witzig auf jeden Fall.
Das ist jetzt für welche Plattform?
Na, App Store. Also für Mac und halt auch Windows. Ja, da steht man ja. Da ist Linux sogar auch, wie ich gerade sehe.
Also kannst du das da kaufen und kannst du auch einen App Store kaufen.
Siehst du gerade hier...
Da, Braid, in der Mitte, da wo 20 Dollar steht, da sehe ich ein Windows Logo, ein Apfel und ein Pinguin.
Soll ich den mal besorgen?
Ja, doch noch keiner verlinkt hier.
Die alle wieder Zeit gehabt hat zu spielen.
Ich nicht, ich sehe das immer bei meinen Kumpels.
Ich habe das, was ich...
Ja, ich habe ja, das war, hat ja alles meine Freundin gespielt. Ich habe ja die Apple gespielt.
So, Braid gibt es im App Store, weil wir sind ja nun mal Mac-User hier. Kostet 2,99 Euro. Ja, könnte man so sehen. Aber wie gesagt, mit dem Feature, dass man die Zeit... Na, man muss halt die Zeit zurückdrehen und dadurch gewisse Sachen lösen. Also es ist echt, manche Sachen sind da tricky. Es ist nicht einfach nur so wie Donkey Kong, sondern... Dann, wenn du die Zeit zurückspulst, dann hörst du auch die Musik rückwärts laufen und der Bildschirm wird dabei so gräulich. Also es geht wirklich alles rückwärts. Außer halt bestimmte Sachen und das ist der Trick, da musst du halt so ein bisschen rumrätseln, wie du das halt lösen kannst.
Die Bewertungen sprechen ja auch so ein bisschen für sich. Hier 22 mal 5 Sterne.
Ja, ich glaube im App Store gibt es das wahrscheinlich dann auch noch nicht so lange, oder? Sonst wären da ein paar mehr Bewertungen.
Ja, ich...
4,6, na doch, gibt es schon eine Weile. Na guckt euch mal an, das ist ganz witzig.
Ich will auch mal auf etwas hinweisen, was ich hier schon länger auf der Liste habe. Ich bin leider immer noch nicht dazu gekommen, es auszuprobieren. Von daher nur der Hinweis, dass es das gibt. Aber ich hab halt immer mal wieder so dieses Bedürfnis, dass ich so von irgendeinem Raum, in dem ich mich oft aufhalte, gerne mal einen dreidimensionalen Plan hätte oder zumindest überhaupt nur irgendwie einen belastbaren Plan. Du kennst dieses Problem mit Ausmessen von Wänden etc., Und dann bin ich auf ein Tool gestoßen fürs iPhone, das heißt Magic Plan. Und wie gesagt, ich kann jetzt noch keine konkreten Ergebnisse vorweisen, aber es gibt da ausführliche Tutorials, die kann man sich auch angucken. Und das Coole ist, dieses Tool basiert da drauf, dass du mit der Kamera einfach die Ecken quasi fotografierst. Da drin diese eigentlichen Winkel, wenn du die nicht sogar selber erkennst, markierst. Und das dann so im Kreis immer vom selben Punkt aus machst. Und eher dann aus diesen Ecken Daten, die du da mit Accelerometer und Büro und Kette warst. Ich verweise einfach mal da drauf, fand das ganz interessant.
Aber kannst du noch jetzt während der Sendung live testen?
Ja, Ecken musst du dann auch freiräumen und pipapo. Also das ist ja auch immer nicht so einfach.
Was ich ja festgestellt habe, ich habe das erste Mal mit meinem iPad 2 ein Foto gemacht. Boah, ist die Kamera darin schlecht. Vullteufel ist die ekelhaft mies. Also wenn man Fotos macht und nur ein iPad hat, dann ist auf jeden Fall die Kamera alleine ein so derartiger Upgrade-Grund gibt es ja gar nicht.
Das ist ja auch in your FaceTime.
Dass die sich so, dass die sich getraut haben, so eine Kamera einzubauen, das hat mich echt schockiert. Also die ist wirklich richtig mies. Also selbst bei tageslicht und idealen Bedingungen ist das so wie Webcam 1999. Also Mülltonne ganz unten, wie Dennis sagen würde. So, das muss doch auch nochmal gesagt werden. iPad 2 Kamera. Ich meine trotzdem, was erlaube.
Ja, was treibst du hier auch mit so Outdates?
Also da wär es echt besser gewesen, die Kamera ganz wegzulassen tatsächlich.
Für Video würd's taugen.
Das ist ja die nach hinten raus, also... Achso. Die eigentlich gute...
Na ja, da machst du auch mit Video.
Ich hab Oma den Schrank gezeigt.
Das ist immer...
Aber hab ich mit... Ich hab mit iPhone dann gemacht, weil iPad... Das war nicht gut.
Gut, Jungs. Wollen wir hier mal zum Ende kommen? Nee, ist ein neuer. Ich bin durch.
Ist ja schon elf, Mensch.
Ich bin ja auch schon hier lange am Start und ich muss morgen früh schon wieder die nächste Live-Sendung machen.
Und die Spieler sind schon längst in der Kabine und geduscht.
Ja, eben, genau.
Und wir sind davon noch weit entfernt.
Die haben ja nichts zu tun.
Da 90 Minuten rumzappeln und dann wartet mit dem Arbeitstag. Na gut, Feierabend.
Feierabend. Hörer, ihr, die ihr wieder so durchgehalten habt, bis zum Ende. Gepreiset seid ihr.
Gepreiset, nicht gepriesen?
Gepriesen, na ja.
Etwas über 400.
Ihr seht schon, das ist wirklich Zeit. Ich rede schon nur noch dummes Zeug. Ja, mal wieder eine gute Gelegenheit, sich auch mal hier zu bedanken. Für vor allem die ganze Hilfe im Chat, also das Live-Publikum. Ist ja sowieso das Tollste. Gleich werden wir aus euren tollen Vorschlägen, die, wie ich es richtig mitbekommen habe, zahlreich sind, den tollen Titel für diese Sendung bestimmen. Danke für die Unterstützung. Und hier geht es bald wieder weiter. Demnächst dann wieder auch mit Max, der war heute bei einer Microsoft-Veranstaltung. Der musste sich schon mal Windows 8 anschauen. Keine Ahnung, wo der steckt, hat irgendwie keine Zeit. Ansonsten haben wir eigentlich schon einen Termin für die nächste Sendung. Ja, haben wir einfach in zwei Wochen.
Bin ich überhaupt da? Moment. Jetzt schauen wir mal in Fantastical, was ich ja immer noch gerne benutze.
Das werden wir gleich feststellen. Ansonsten schieben wir da noch ein bisschen rum. Wer Interesse hat und jetzt gerade nicht live hört, wir sind immer nachzuschlagen, mobimex.dl slash live da ist immer der Kalender. Den könnt ihr euch auch abonnieren, wenn ihr es ganz hart braucht. Ansonsten kann man da auch einfach mal nachschlagen. Ansonsten ist immer klug uns auf Twitter zu folgen oder auch dort Kommentare zur Sendung zu hinterlassen, uns zu flattern oder andere lustige Dinge mit unserer Webseite zu machen. Aber nicht Harken.
Harken?
Dann zeigen wir euch mal, was eine Hacke ist. Bevor es noch schlimmer wird.
Gruseln Sie alle aus dem Kanal.
Sagen wir alle Tschüss.
Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.